now
live right good afternoon everybody uh
welcome back to the inquiry we'll resume
proceedings um we're due to hear now the
council's evidence as I said earlier on
this morning um uh and there's only one
witness I think Mr Coleman so I'll uh
allow Mr wil to uh introduce his first
witness thank you thank you very much
sir uh Mr Coleman I'll introduce you to
the inquiry your name is David Coleman
you hold an MA in planning policy and
practice from London South Bank
University and an upper second class
honors degree in geography from the
University of Liverpool you've been a
town planner for nearly 20 years with a
variety of senior positions in both the
public and private sectors you're also a
charter member of the rtpi and a member
of The Institute of of leadership you're
the managing director and founder of DAC
planning which you established in 2016
to provide advice and support to local
authorities local communities and public
sector bodies nationally your company
specializes in developing skills and
capacity in local government supporting
plan making and infrastructure planning
you also support local authorities with
planning appeals research and
evidence-base Gathering you're based at
the University of essex's Innovation
Center in Colchester your proof goes on
to uh describe the range of experiences
that you've had professionally I won't
read all of them out save that you note
in paragraph 1.4 of your proof that
between 2010 and 2016 you worked for
Malden Council where you led the
production and independent examination
of the local development
plan uh Mr Coleman if you can just turn
please to paragraph
1.10 of your proof of evidence page
four where you've set out your
professional declaration can you just
confirm orally to the inquiry please
that that declaration remains true today
absolutely yes thank you as I indicated
earlier on sir I don't propose to have
Mr Coleman read out Chu his proof rather
I'm going to focus in questions on what
seem to me to be the the key points that
will most help you what I'd like to
begin with with that in mind Mr Coleman
is the context within which lendon sits
within the wider District area and if we
could begin please by taking up core
document 3.1 which is the ldp
itself and within that document going to
page
perhaps Mr Coleman you can explain for
the benefit of the inquiry with within
the key plan diagram we find there where
latchingdon is and how it's located
within what's been referred to as the
DJI Peninsula please yes certainly um so
as you said this is the key diagram from
the local development plan so it shows
you the district and I think it's
helpful to see the context
um geographically of the district and of
where latchingdon sits within that
context so as you rightly said um
essentially the area to the south of the
Black Water
estry um to the south and east of molden
and haybridge um and to the north of
burnam mon Crouch is the the denji
Peninsula so you have the black wry to
the north the North Sea to the East and
the Crouch to the South so um
it's essentially um access is out to the
West um so latchington sits fairly
centrally within the Deni Peninsula orbe
it um obviously slightly to the West um
if you can see it it's uh mland is
highlighted as is southminster as they
are larger Villages um lingon I hope you
can see is just to the south west of
mland um and as I said already to the
southeast of
mden and in terms of the characteristics
of the denji Peninsula as a as a as a
geographical area what what are the
features which which Define the
peninsula please um the peninsula itself
is is actually surprisingly remote um
for somewhere that's only 60 70 miles
from
London um so as you've heard already the
the roads are uh quite rural um there
are no a
roads um there is a train line in the
south of the denji Peninsula which is a
Branch line which serves burnam mon
Crouch and
southminster um but the denji Peninsula
itself is very
open um flat flat land uh predominantly
agricultural in
nature um and the agricultural past has
shaped helped to shape the form of the
village and the roads that sit there now
so the there are a range of small and
mediumsized and larger Villages um small
small rural settlements that sit across
the denji um but there is I would say
quite a special character to the area um
certainly quite surprising for um for
those who don't know the area and
haven't haven't visited um so that kind
of unique rural character
um has helped to shape the the
characteristics of the individual
settlements within
there zooming in a little bit then to
the uh the more immediate surroundings
of latching D can we pleas please take
up Mr mil's proof of
evidence and on page 67 of that
document we find a very helpful OS
map of the The Wider Deni pinula
centered on
[Applause]
lcha this is the
um
it's it's described as proof plan cm1
the bigger document is it I think it's
I've actually got a different page
number um oh have you okay your I've got
page number 35 35 35 okay it's 67 in M
that's
okay see as long as we're all looking
it's a proof plan
cm1
now in terms of what we can see on this
plan Mr Coleman now now we're all
looking at at the right thing what this
OS map helpfully allows us to do is to
see some of the shapes and
characteristics of the settlements
around lingon as well as lingon itself
what are the characteristic features if
any of the settlements in this part of
the denji Peninsula that you'd like to
draw to the inspector's attention please
uh thank you yes I think the the key
features I I'd like to highlight are the
the straight and then abruptly curving
roads so if you look at where
latchington is in the in the center of
the the plan you'll see the lingon road
to the West um you'll see that that from
cold Norton travels East in a fairly
straight line and then abruptly turns
southwards before turning eastwards
again
um so these bends um are features of the
the
roads uh within the denji area and
you'll see that the shape of the
settlements The Villages sit neatly
within those curves or around those
curves and the settlements themselves
are generally linear in nature so they
follow the path of that
road um and you can see obviously oror
is a good good example obviously there's
some newer development there which has
changed the shape slightly but you can
see that the the patterns of the
settlements the shapes of the
settlements are relatively
regular um and yes follow the the the
road the Dynamics of the road if you
like and the the curves and the bends in
the
road thank you continuing on the theme
of the character of settlements on the
denji Peninsula can we have a look next
please at the characterization
assessment which is core document 3
20 thank you and within thank you sir
within the document uh El ronic page 10
please hard copy page
six we find the classification of the
settlement so it tells you for each
settlement within the area what sort of
type what typology it falls within and
what how is latchingdon
identified within paragraph 3.4 of this
typology list please it's identified as
an agricultural
settlement thank you and if we can go on
to hard uh forgive me to PDF page 55
please which is going to be hard copy
page
51 we find here this document's uh this
document's description of the key
characteristics of the Agricultural
settlements are there any particular
points here you'd like to draw to the
inspector's attention Mr colan
um I think it's useful to to see that
the that there are um common
characteristics to these types of
settlements um so you can see that
they're located above reclaim marshes on
Clay lands
um they're in areas of early open field
enclosure often have nucleated or linear
forms that were well established by the
late medieval
period um the majority of villages for
the majority of the villages the Parish
church is still the dominant
architectural statement and stands at
the heart of the
Village um sorry I was just going to say
that the the um document goes on to then
explain in more detail a number of
different characteristics of these
Villages thank you and in terms of how
how if at all the document can help us
on how those key characteristics are to
be protected can we go on please to page
65 hard copy 61
where we have a list of what I described
as specific policies I should stress so
these aren't development plan policies
these are um what I call policies within
the characterization
assessment and what if any assistance Mr
common can the inspector draw from the
first of those policies policy 6.1
please um so the first policy is um
suggested The prominent linear form of
the settlement should be maintained and
closes and cacks should be
avoided thank you very much now I'd like
to have a look at latchin in itself now
continuing to zoom in we started with
the peninsula as a whole then we looked
more locally and now we're going to look
at latching itself for this please can
you take up your proof of
evidence
and we're going to go to Pages 18 and 19
please and we'll begin please with
figure
4.22.18
um as at 2000 you can still clearly see
I would I would say the the historic
core of the village around um the church
and the the main Junction that you you
heard about earlier this morning
um you can see there's been um some
growth um particularly to to the east of
Burnham
Road um which but but generally the the
pattern of the development follows the
linear form of of the
road and how what's your assessment of
how that pattern relates to the the
denji Peninsular pattern of settlements
that we looked at in the
characterization assessment I'd say it's
broadly consistent um and certainly this
this would have the settlement would
have looked more or less like this at
the time the characterization assessment
was was being being developed I would
imagine so that traditional form uh
linear nature is is relatively
intact uh moving from 2000 to the
present please on the previous page page
18 you have figure 4.22.18
which the key tells us are approved
applications above five dwellings
outside of the settlement boundary and
the key tells us that since
2014 what's your assessment please of
the the character of latchingdon in
terms of the denji Peninsula points
we've talked about when we take into
account these further
permissions um you can see the the
number of firstly the number of
permissions has been considerable since
2014 um so the green the green areas um
all of which are located outside of the
settlement boundary so the settlement
boundary which is the black line and as
identified in the ldp is essentially
seeking to retain the the more
traditional form of the
settlement um the green areas are are
and the new permissions are starting to
a
road generally uh starting to a road
that albeit
on the whole following a linear
pattern um in that they are following
the the shape of the road if you like um
extending the built area further to the
South
generally thank you keeping that plan
page open and in the light of the points
we've just talked about I'd like to ask
you some questions about your what in
your view will be the impact of The
Proposal on latching them please now I
think I can lead you on the fact that
the proposal involves 160 units can you
help the inspector on the area of the
appeal site please um the appeal site is
10 12 or 10 10.1 hectares in size okay
and do are you aware of what the area is
of the latchingdon settlement boundary
as drawn by the development plan the
settlement boundary in the development
plan is 19 hectar in size
in terms then of a of a 19 hectare
settlement with a a 10.1 hectare
addition of new development what's your
assessment of the impact of The Proposal
in terms of scale on the identity of the
Village um the appeal proposal if
allowed would extend the cment boundary
obviously considerably to the east um
increasing the size by 53% so it
represent a 53% increase in the
settlement area or sorry the defined
settlement boundary area it doesn't
include the other sites that have have
consent outside of the
boundary now you mentioned there the 53%
increase can you expand please on the
point you made about pulling the
boundary to the east what what what
would be the effect of The Proposal on
the shape of the settlement in your
assessment
essentially it's it's adding a a
significant area um
currently uh in use as agricultural
fields to to the east of the the
settlement um essentially breaking the
the linear pattern um it's extending
further east away from Burnham
Road uh into the countryside the
southern Edge is obviously going to
follow the the southern sorry is going
to is going to extend along Burnham road
but essentially it's an extension of the
The
Village um out e sorry out Eastward away
from the the linear form further eroding
the the character or that traditional um
character of an agricultural settlement
that we referred to
before and drawing the threads of that
little section of every evence together
then what's your overall assessment
please taking into account the size of
the development and the shape of the
development relative to the settlement
what your overall assessment please of
the impact of The Proposal on the
character and identity of
latching um I would I would say it would
fundamentally change the the character
and identity
by extending the develop extending the
the built developed area to the
East um changing the pattern uh less
linear in
nature um and the scale of the proposed
development uh would be out of keeping
with the the village and the the rural
the rural identity um and the identity
as an agricultural
settlement thank you and with with page
18 still open is there anything you'd
like to say in terms of the cumulative
impact of The Proposal given the
existing missions identified there in
green what's the cumulative impact if
any on latchingdon
character and identity please um well I
think it's considerable cumulatively um
in isolation it's it's already quite
considerable
um just bear with
[Applause]
me obviously the qu quantity of homes
that have already been
permitted um I think it's 100 I'm just
trying to see it's 162 so on the
previous page of my proof of evidence
page
17 there's a table that sets
out um the sites um that are shown in
green essentially on on the plan on page
18 so these are sites that are outside
of the settlement boundary for five or
more dwellings and have um obtained
planning consent since the plan period
started started in
2014 so these sites total 162
dwellings with the addition of a of
another 160 dwellings as
proposed um this would obviously
cumulatively um become very considerable
so um and just by just by way of context
for that what's the what's the size of
latchingdon in terms of dwelling numbers
uh without the 162 just referred
to so it's um approximately so I'm just
looking for the number approximately 500
dwellings in latchington and that's
based on sensus
information sorry I've um so it's
paragraph 4.14 of my my proof so
according to the 2011 census there were
491 households in latchingdon in
2011 so with an addition
of 160
dwellings
um that would increase the number of
households or dwellings in the village
from and these are approximate numbers
491 to
651 and that would represent a 30
approximately 33% increase in the total
number of dwellings in the
village if you look at that cumulatively
with the the existing consented
development shown
on page 17 in the table 4.
22.1
um you would uh well the total number of
dwellings equates to 322
dwellings
um which represents a 6 66% increase in
the total number of dwellings in
latchingdon
um as well as the considerable increase
to the the builtup area that we we've
already referred
to changing subject then slightly Mr
Coleman I'd like to I'd like to look now
at the the what are agreed to be the key
relevant policies of the local plan
please if we can take up core document
3.1
which is where we find it and we're
going to begin within cor document 3.1
please on page
14 where we will find policy S1 which is
the first of the three policies I'm
going to ask you
about perhaps by way of introduction to
the to the policy Mr Coleman can you can
you help the inspect Spector with the
structure and the purpose of policy S1
within the ldp
please yes certainly policy S1 is as it
says entitled sustainable development
and it's the first policy of the plan
it's a strategic policy which is
intended to provide the overall
direction um for the for the policies of
the plan and for um development
proposals that that follow um it's sets
out the presumption in favor of
sustainable development um and provides
a number of key principles for policy
and decision-
making at looking at those key
principles please can we begin with
principle
two which is the delivery of a
sustainable level of housing growth that
will meet local needs and deliver a wide
choice of high quality homes in the most
sustainable locations what's your
assessment please of the appeal proposal
against that principle
my assessment is that the appeal
proposal is contrary to this uh criteria
of the the policy um
the the policy states delivering a
sustainable level of housing growth to
meet local needs and deliver the choice
of homes in the most sustainable
locations um that's then a thread that
runs through the plan in terms of where
the growth is planned to take place um
and how the rest of the policies are
then structured which which I'm sure
we're going to come on
to so my assessment is that
this uh this proposal in the context of
this policy requirement um the proposed
development um is uh does not represent
a sustainable level of housing growth to
meet local
needs um and it isn't in one of the most
sustainable locations because they are
the locations that are identified by the
ldp um through the allocations and other
policies of the plan
moving on to principle three we have
promote the effective use of land and
prioritize development on previously
developed land and plan Planned growth
in the garden suburbs and strategic
allocations uh same question please how
do you assess the proposal against the
requirements of principle
three and my assessment is that the
proposal is contrary to to this part of
the
policy um it does not promote the
effective use of land um which is uh
obviously something that the mppf
encourages and the ldp seeks to carry
forward um and it does not prioritize
development on previously developed land
or planned growth at Garden suburbs and
strategic allocations um it's a
Greenfield site um outside of settlement
boundaries so contrary to to that part
of the
policy and final principle I want to ask
you about please is principle 12 towards
the bottom of the page which is to
maintain the rural character of The
District without compromising the
identity of its individual settlements
again please can we have your assessment
of The Proposal against principle
12 um again my assessment is that the
proposal is contrary to this part of the
policy um as as just discussed I don't I
don't believe it to be in keeping with
um the identity of of the set
of latchington and I don't believe it
contributes towards maintaining the
rural character of The District um so I
do believe it would compromise the
identity of latchingdon and therefore be
contrary to this uh given the the views
you've given about principles 2 3 and 12
what's your assessment of The Proposal
against policy S1 as a whole please uh
my assessment is that the polic uh the
proposal is contrary to policy S1 as a
whole and final question on S1 uh is in
respect of its of its consistency or
non-c consistency as as as you'll tell
us with the current version of the mppf
how do you how do you assess whether or
not this policy is up to date in mppf
terms please um so so obviously we're
required to look at as youve said how
how consistent this policy is um all of
the policies when determining how much
weight to to give the policy um and the
policy is more than 5 years
old um but my my interpretation for this
or my view for for the purposes of this
uh inquiry this appeal is that this
policy is wholly consistent with
national planning policy um it was
produced and examined under the mppf
2012 um but I am comfortable that this
policy is uh remains in accordance
with um with with the mppf as a whole
and um I believe it should be given full
weight in that
regard thank you very much if we can
move on please to page 17 within the
document we find policy
S2 I'd like to take a similar structure
of questions please in respect of this
policy so first of all what's the
structure and purpose of policy S2 as
you understand it please Mr Coleman um
policy S2 uh entitled Strate IC growth
is there to essentially set out how the
council um and how the plan will meet
the needs of the district over the plan
period which runs to
2029 so it provides the direction and
the locations for growth to meet the
needs um the needs as defined by the
plan objectively assessed needs were 310
homes per
anom
um and the the policy set sets out a
number of elements or provides a number
of elements as to how how these needed
to be met it then goes on to actually
quantify the needs um by location and
type of development um Housing
Development coming forward so I I should
qualify when when it talks about housing
sorry when it talks about meeting the
needs it's meeting the housing
needs um not employment needs that's
that's dealt with separately so the
policy itself
um clearly signals that the majority of
New Growth will be delivered through
sustainable extensions to molden
haybridge and burnam on crouch in the
form of garden suburbs and strategic
allocations uh those locations are the
largest settlements in the in the
district
um and in in fact the only the only
towns in the district all the other
settlements um are are smaller in
nature um
it's clear that the scale and you type
use and form of development should
reflect the role of those
areas um it does make clear that a
proportion of new development will be
directed to the rural villages to
support rural housing needs local
services and facilities and the rural
economy strategic growth in those areas
in the rur rural villages will be
related to the settlement hierarchy will
reflect the size function and physical
capacity of the set and will not result
in unsustainable spatial patterns to the
detriment of The Wider
area um it talks about infrastructure
constraints um which were a key
determinant in in setting that grve
strategy do you want me to just and in
and in terms of how you assess the
appeal proposal and the appeal site
against the structure purpose and
requirements of policy S2 what's your
what's your assessment please uh my
assessment is that the proposal doesn't
um Accord
with policy S2 as a whole because it
doesn't Accord with any of the
categories of growth that have been
identified in policy S2 so over over
leaf on page
18 um the policy sets out those sources
of of Supply to meet the
needs um it sorts out sorry it sets out
um a supply of H housing which is over
and above the objectively assessed needs
of the the plan so that's just to remind
you
4,650 homes required a minimum the plan
seeks to deliver
5,18 and the categories that are shown
on the table on page 18 there are two
categories that are potentially relevant
to growth of this
nature uh one is neighborhood plans
where 100 units were identified and the
other is a winful allowance where 300
units were identified across the plan
period
I do I don't well I'm I'm confident that
the proposed development doesn't fit
into any of those categories for the
reasons which um I can
explain thank you and final question on
S2 what's your assessment of its
consistency with the mppf please um
again I I I am comfortable that the
policy and the spatial strategy is
consistent with the
mppf um there are some changes to the
mppf clearly that um will need to be uh
looked at by the council um such as a
requirement for small sites and I
haven't looked at that in detail um but
as a whole in terms of how this uh
policy sits with national policy I'm I'm
comfortable that it's it's it's
consistent with national
policy um and therefore I believe uh
full weight should be applied to this
policy thank you can we then go next
please to S8 which you find at page
thank you thank you uh again similar
similar structure what's the structure
and purpose of S8
please um S8 is really directed towards
um the countryside area areas and to
settlement boundaries so areas outside
of the the main towns and the
allocations um this provides for a
settlement hierarchy for the
district um you'll see there four four
categories main settlements larger
Villages and smaller Villages and lastly
other Villages and where do we see
latchingdon within that latchingdon sits
within the category of smaller
Villages um the policy goes on to
explain um
again an important thread through the
plan that the countryside will be
protected for its landscape natural
resources and ecological value as well
as it as its intrinsic character and
Beauty um outside of defined settlement
boundaries the garden suburbs and the
allocations planning permission for
development will only be granted where
the intrinsic character and beauty of
the countryside is not adversely
impacted upon and provided it is for and
then the policy goes on to set out a
series of uses um which as long as they
don't impact upon the intrinsic
character and beauty of the countryside
um would be acceptable could be
acceptable and in terms of that that
list of uses that could be acceptable
subject to the impact point you
described how how does the appeal
proposal fit against those please and
the app appeal proposal doesn't Accord
with any of those
categories
thank you um again following the
structure of my previous questions how
do you assess the consistency of this
policy against the mppf please um in a
similar way I'm I'm comfortable that the
policy as a whole is consistent with the
nppf thank you very much um final
question I want to ask you please in
respect
of this uh policy in policy S8 is about
its restrictive nature and on on the
subject of mppf compliance a point
that's made by Mr Armstrong is that the
policy is a restrictive one and so may
to that extent be contrary to the
mppf what's your assessment please of Mr
Armstrong's approach to the restrictive
nature of this
policy um I fundamentally would disagree
with with it being inconsistent
um in that way and with it being overly
restrictive um the plan was produced and
examined under the mppf
2012 um and there there haven't been
significant changes to the mppf in that
time um that would mean that uh it was
possible to have a restrictive policy
then but it isn't now um I would argue
that
the uh General requirements in the mppf
in terms of what how how restrictive
policies should or should not be have
not have not changed
greatly um I would also add that this
was an issue that was considered as were
many many issues through the examination
of the the plan
itself and because of the importance of
the issue the inspector of the for the
local plan
examination um that in his report made
made specific comment on this
issue um his his report if I may is CD
3.16 and it's paragraph 121 of his
report which I think you set at and your
proof so we can avoid opening it's 3
point uh 3.6 3.16 and it this is this is
also in paragraph 3 sorry 4.31 of my
proof may may avoid opening another
document sir just for a reference that's
in the Pro
yeah right
yes this was 2017 wasn't it the uh this
was the the inspector's report yes
yeah and short short question Mr Colman
did the what was the examining
inspector's assessment of the suggestion
that the policy was was uh restrictive
in a way that created an mppf problem uh
he he concluded that the approach taken
by policy s is consistent with the
framework's core planning principles it
strikes a suitable balance between
recognizing the intrinsic character and
beauty of the country side and
supporting the thriving rural
communities within
it thank you now obviously in 2017 the
examining inspector would have been
looking at the 2012 mppf have there been
any relevant changes between 2012 and
20123 in the mppf in respect of of that
analysis um no I don't believe so thank
you another point the appellant makes in
respect of the agreed conflicts with the
three policy policies we looked at is
that they are uh I think Mr Armstrong's
work word is technical conflicts do you
have any comment you wish to make on on
that approach to policy analysis and
policy
compliance
um I I believe that a proposal should be
either judged to be in accordance with
or not in accordance with a policy or a
development plan as a whole um the basis
of decision- making is as we as as you
will well know SE section 386 of the
planning and compulsory Purchase Act and
that requires decisions to be taken in
accordance with the development plan
unless material considerations indicate
otherwise um this uh is is not just a
technical
um issue in terms of compliance it is
not compliant and I don't I don't think
there is
a I don't think there is a category for
technical
non-compliance uh changing subject then
slightly Mr Coleman I want to ask you a
few questions about housing land supply
please now it's it's agreed between the
main parties that the land Supply
position is currently
5.97 years what are the implication
ations of that State of Affairs for this
proposal please in terms of How It's
assessed against the mppf in particular
um so for the purposes of the mppf that
means that the the Tilted balance um or
paragraph 11d doesn't
apply um so whereas previously the
settlement boundaries would have been
considered out of date um when there is
no 5year land Supply where there is a
5-year land Supply the settlement
boundaries are fully uh fully enforc if
you like and a full policy consideration
so I think it changes the way that the
proposal is is viewed considerably and
you'll recall when we looked in your
proof at page 18 we saw the the
currently consented developments in the
plan period which were shown in the
green boxes they were described in your
table 4. 22.1 as well at the time that
those permissions were
granted
could the council demonstrate a
five-year housing land Supply or
not and I couldn't be couldn't give you
a categoric answer to that but my
understanding is that there wasn't a
5-year land Supply there certainly
for uh a significant period of time
after the adoption of the plan um the
council has has not been able to um
demonstrate a fiveyear land
supply thank you can we take up next
please still on the theme of land Supply
core doc
3.3 where we will
find I hope the 2022 23
AMR right thank
you
this is the latest one is
it2
yes you and uh within the AMR Mr common
we find we find in particular a couple
of tables I'd like to begin please with
table one which is on page
one that shows housing delivery over the
development plan period it gives us
reach Year from 2014 15 to
2223 the annual requirement net recorded
completions and then shortfall or
Surplus for each year uh what if
anything Mr Coleman do you take from
that data about the direction of travel
of housing delivery in the molden
district please is it getting better or
worse or is it the same it's
considerably better over recent years
how how do we how do we see that can you
yeah certainly so if you look at the
final column that shows short for and
surplus for each year you'll see that
each year is is being monitored against
an annual requirement of 310 homes per
year which is the requirement in the ldp
policy
S2
um just to note that that's not the same
as local housing need which is now now
less but when looking at this the
performances that's shown um for the
first few years of the plan period so
2014 until
201718 um you'll see that there was a
deficit against the
requirement um I know firsthand that
that was because at least in part if not
considerably because the plan was going
through local plan examination so it
wasn't fully uh in place it wasn't
approved at that
point the plan was approved in 2017 by
the Secretary of State and you can see
from 2018 19
onwards um a dramatically improving
pattern so 152 above the requirement in
201920 116 above in 2020
2021 there is a a reduction after that
it's still above the requirement but
it's not as far above the requirement
and I would
um I would suggest that that that covid
and a pandemic would have had some at
least something to do with that and even
during those times the the district or
the council was still delivering a level
of housing which was above the 310
annual housing
requirement most recently 2022 to
2023 um 449 homes were delivered against
a requirement of
310 so over this over over the plan
period as a whole um against the 310
requirement there is a cumulative short
4 of 109 but you can see that the
direction of travel is very much that
that looks like it will be addressed um
obviously I can't speculate U for sure
but it looks like it will be addressed
if the pattern continues of overd
delivering as we've seen in the last
four years four monitoring
years and on the theme of future
delivery can we turn the page please to
table two of the the most recent
AMR what we have here are the ldp
allocations
identified we have the housing
trajectory for each allocation uh and
it's planning permission net capacity we
have what it should have delivered by
the monitoring year its actual delivery
to the monitoring year and then that
expressed as a
percentage uh what can the inspector
take
from this data about the prospects of
future housing delivery in the district
St I think you can read this in one of
two ways you you can see that this is
showing
that everything that was expected to be
delivered hasn't been delivered or I
would argue more importantly you can see
that this means that there are a large
number of um consents and schemes in the
pipeline that are yet to deliver but
will be delivering so for instance
s2a which is uh north um sorry it's
South moden Garden suburb
um is allocated for a thousand
dwellings um and still has a good
proportion of
those uh over a half still to be
delivered the same with North hybridge
Garden suburb so there is considerable
progress I'm aware being made on these
sites um which I don't from to the best
of my knowledge is isn't going to to
stop in the near future so the the
pipeline and the future Supply is
looking very positive
um so I I I take comfort from from that
table and then final couple of questions
from me Mr Colman before I hand you over
to my LED friend about your assess your
assessment forgive me of the planning
balance overall now you've you've you've
told us in evidence
that your assessment is that the
proposal is in conflict with the three
key development plan policies were
identified in your proof you identify
and apply weight to to a number of
planning benefits and as the inspector
seen those we don't need to go through
them perhaps can you can you give the
inspector your overall assessment on
whether the planning benefits of the
scheme as you've identified them do or
don't outweigh the development plan
conflict um put put plainly I I don't
believe that the benefits outweigh the
conflict with the development plan I
think um the starting point is the
development plan it's agreed that this
proposed development is contrary to
those three key policies fre key
relevant policies of the development
plan S1 S2 and S8 and whilst I
acknowledge that there are uh
considerable benefits that that would be
offered by the scheme I I simply don't
believe that those would overcome that
conflict with with the development
plan Mr Coleman bear with me one second
thank you very much Mr Coleman so those
are my questions in Chief I think I came
in at just about 45 minutes pretty
impressive than not a bad estimate very
very good um are you ready to go
straight away um well I think so so
because I think we're going to be tied
to to I mean to be honest um Mr kanuk if
if we don't finish
I we'll just have to accept that
um that uh we we have a situation which
is a rather unfortunate situation where
Mr Coleman you know is restri in in
restriction o overnight um I'm grateful
for that so because what what I don't
want is to sort of
artificially Rush yeah yeah I I think um
you know
that particularly with these new rules
that have now been introduced these the
this new guidance where where people are
under restrictions as soon as they take
the stand it seems to me that that gives
much less flexibility in terms of people
not being under restriction so if it if
it comes to it I mean there's a limit
frankly to the amount of information one
can take in I as I said in opening you
know I I don't I'm not a fan of late
night sitting for for inquiries because
I just find levels of concentration
begin to to dip um so I'm more than
happy uh for you to you know take the
time you need um and and we'll we'll see
how we get on I mean I was hoping also
to have them a midaf afternoon break at
some point so I mean perhaps yeah we we
can have a break at a suitable um
juncture as it were well by by all means
uh so I'm happy to do what what I can to
assist you and if it assists Mr Coleman
the answer to all of my questions is yes
and uh do that we'll make uh we'll make
better a PR I mean the other thing of
course is there's only one uh witness
for the council so you know it's
inevitable that you're you probably got
a lot of questions to ask ask him you
know if if we had a whole series of
council Witnesses then you know that so
it's inevitable that Mr Coleman as it
were will be answering a lot of
questions I imagine so okay if if you'd
like to proceed Mr KCK thank you um Mr
Coleman just a couple of questions about
your instruction please uh you ceased
working for this Authority in 2016
didn't you yes that's correct you had no
involvement in the validation or
assessment of the application did you no
none whatsoever uh you had no role in
the officer's report and the
recommendation for approval did you uh
no none whatsoever you were instructed
after members had resolved to refuse
planning permission contrary to the
officer recommendation weren't you
correct yes
um now uh turn if you need to to the
statement of common ground but we can
agree that at the time of the
determination by members there were no
outstanding requests for further
information were there no that's correct
there was no criticism of the scope or
method of any of the technical
assessments was there no correct there
was no objection from statutory consules
was there uh all all objections have
been overcome as I understand it yeah
there were no technical objections to
the application from anyone in fact were
there no uh there was no criticism of
the technical assessments at all was
there no no competing technical
assessments correct yes no and um the
recommendation for approval was the
recommendation of the case officer Mr
March endorsed by the director of
Service delivery correct correct and you
have no criticism of the officer
reporting your evidence do you uh no not
explicitly no no I I I I I get the point
that you disagree with the conclusion um
at the time of the determination then
there was a powerful consensus of
professional evidence unanimous in
supporting the scheme wasn't there uh
there was and it's reasonable to attach
significant weight to that consensus
reached in accordance with practice set
out in the mppf isn't
it I take a a very different View to
that of the officer who who wrote the
report and particularly in terms of how
the the weight that was attributed to
the development plan and the role that
the development plan had in the
determination of the application Okay
the reason for refusal um you have it in
your evidence at 2.4
please and we know that reasons for
refusal must be fallen State clearly and
precisely the full reasons for refusal
mustn't they
yes and you don't suggest that the
authority has failed to comply with that
statutory Duty do you uh no I do not and
so if I look at it what it's saying
is um The Proposal was not considered
sustainable development by reason solely
of its location outside the settlement
boundary
correct
um it depend it depends on your reading
of of that reason for refusal not it's
because it's because it's contrary to
the policies of the local development
plan well let's do it in stages it says
by reason of its location outside of the
settlement boundary it does not
represent sustainable development so the
sole reason for it not being sustainable
development is its location out inside
the settlement boundary correct I think
the um the reason for refusal needs to
be looked at as a whole because it goes
on to to talk about the adverse impacts
of The Proposal um that they would
outweigh the benefits and that that
being contrary to the stated policies of
the molden local development plan yeah
it says
accordingly so that is accordingly is
referring to the settlement boundary
point the adverse impacts would outweigh
any benefits
correct uh I don't see anything in there
other than the location outside the
settlement boundary do I I I think you
need
to I I believe it needs to be read as a
whole and I believe it's talking about
the set the location outside of the
settlement boundary does not therefore
represent sustainable development and
the proposal would not outweigh the
benefits of the development and that is
as a whole contrary to those policies of
the local development plan yes it's
because of its location out the side the
settlement boundaries that the adverse
impacts outweigh the benefits and that
represents the conflict with policies S1
S2 and S8 correct yes yes it's contrary
to those
policies um and so I see then in the
reason for refusal which clearly and
precisely sets out the full reasons for
refusal no reference to the identity and
character of the settlement do I that's
within policy S1 yes and I don't see any
other adverse land use consequence which
might flow from a location on the other
side of the settlement boundary do
I well I believe that there are so let's
start with a yes or no I don't see any
reference in the reason for refusal
which clearly and precisely sets out the
full reasons for refusal any reference
to any adverse land use consequence
which might flow from a location on the
other side of the settlement boundary do
I no not explicitly no correct so let's
turn then please to the development plan
CD
3.1 and the development plan is the
molden local development plan 2014 to
2029 isn't it yes correct and it was
adopted in 2017 and it's more than 5
years old isn't it it yeah it was
approved by the Secretary of State it
wasn't adopted by the council yes and it
runs for a 15-year period between 2014
and 2029 doesn't it yes
correct and we see in fact that point
it's at
119 the inspector submitted his report
directly to the Secretary of State who
approve the plan on the 21st of July
correct right now if I ask you to turn
please to policy
S2
uh and that's on page 17 of the
PDF so
policy uh no sorry it's hard copy page
17 yeah PDF page 21 what this is setting
out is a minimum requirement of 4650
units 2014 to 2029 isn't it correct yes
and that's a minimum of 310 dwellings
per anom isn't it yes and if I just ask
you to turn to the inspector's report
please CD
316 I have the inspect uh the the the
report of Inspector Simon Barkley dated
the 29th of June 2017 do you have
that yes I have that and could you find
please paragraph
61 and that's on page 13 of
55 yes and so what happened is there was
a draft report which set out a housing
requirement of 294 dwellings perom which
soror oh apologies sir paragraph 611
page 13
thank
you um apology sir I was keeping my eye
on uh on uh Mr Coleman
um so Pol the draft policy had set out a
requirement of 294 hadn't it and the
council proposed to modify this to a
requirement of 4650 310 dwellings per
anom correct yes that's correct and the
reason for that essentially
uh is twofold firstly if one looks at
paragraph 62 because out migration from
London was likely to increase over the
plan period correct correct and secondly
if one looks at paragraph 63 the second
and more fundamental reason related to
the plan's aspirations for economic
growth and job creation didn't it uh yes
I would add though
that um there's further context to
to that work which isn't in this in this
report um I commissioned that report on
behalf of the council um that that came
basically this is the assessing M's
housing requirement report August
2014 and it was clear at the time um I'm
sure you remember there was a lot of
confusion at that point in time as to
what objectively assessed needs for
housing actually was and how it should
be calculated so this was a report that
was commissioned during the examination
process um to try and provide more
clarity and it came up with a an upper
and a lower range for what oan could be
and it said it would be prudent to go
for the upper range for those two
reasons so just wanted to clarify it's
just a slight difference in yeah I I'm
not too too interested in some of the
weeds of that I've I've read the report
to a certain extent if it helps you
paragraph 65 of the inspector refers to
the 257 DPA being the unrounded oan I'm
not too interested as it were about the
household projections ultimately what
happened is because of what was then
called a stage two
assessment there was a plan aspiration
for economic job uh for economic growth
and job creation and there was an aim
and the aim is extant in policy E1 to
create a minimum of 2,000 net additional
jobs by 2029 wasn't there that's correct
and does Remain the extant minimum job
creation in policy E1 doesn't it it does
and and so the approach taken by the
council endorsed by the inspector was
that there should be a minimum of 310
dwellings per anom which was necessary
to support that level of economic growth
correct uh correct yes and the figure if
one looks at paragraph 65 the figure of
the unrounded oan would lead to an
inadequate working age population
correct correct yes and and so if I look
then please at paragraph 65 it was on
that basis that the inspector concluded
the figure of 310 dwellings perum was
both necessary and Justified correct
correct and we can agree that that
figure of 310 dwellings per anom then is
a minimum requirement isn't it it is to
support a required Workforce against a
minimum economic growth and job creation
policy requirement correct
uh yes that's correct uh if I turn then
please to policy
S2 so back to CD
3.1 so uh PDF page 21 of CD 3.1 and
policy S2 then was identifying a minimum
of
4650 and a supply of 500 ,18 wasn't it
yes correct and if I scroll through to
the table on the next page I see that
that Supply
comprised
completions extant planning
permissions allocations at molden
haybridge burnam on Crouch an allowance
from ndp's neighborhood plans and a
modest windfall allowance correct
yes and then the space
distribution of that Supply in policy S2
and if it helps you look at
227 the spatial distribution was
essentially
twofold firstly the policy sought to
contain the mo majority of housing
within an adjacent to main settlements
didn't it yes and then secondly if one
looks at
229 a small proportion of growth was
allocated to the district's rural
villages to to help maintain sustainable
rural communities correct correct and
there was then that 100 unit allowance
in the NDP allowance correct
correct and then if we think about the
settlement boundaries then because in
that
context the settlement boundaries were
drawn tightly around the existing
settlements as they were in 2014 and the
proposed allocations weren't they yes
and so the role of the settlement
boundaries was essentially
twofold
firstly to provide an area inside of
which housing was Primer facially
acceptable to meet the minimum housing
requirement yes and
secondly an area outside of which
housing was in principle not acceptable
subject to the restrictions uh the
restricted exceptions in S8 because it
wasn't needed to meet the minimum
housing requirement correct
yes and so the spatial strategy to 2029
was very
simple firstly promote housing inside
the settlement boundaries and on the
allocations at the three main
settlements
secondly restrict housing in the lower
tier settlements save through
ndps and thirdly restrict Market housing
as a spatial approach outside settlement
boundaries correct
yes and that restriction on Market
housing outside settlement boundaries
was without a consideration of their
merits wasn't it in policy
terms uh yes but there was uh
consideration through the
plan examination
process um of a a larger allowance for
rural rural
allocations um that I can't remember the
quantum think it was 300 homes I need to
check but that ended
up not being taken into the final
approved
plan because the the district did not
have a 5-year land Supply and because of
the extensive examination which went on
for two to three years um a lot of
windall schemes or or schemes came
forward outside of settlement boundaries
which essentially used up that allowance
before the plan could be approved okay
so that's why that just just wanted to
clarify wor of thing no I I I don't want
to get wrapped up in in the different
spatial growth options that were
considered as part of the plan we've
we've we've got the plan here but but
thank you for that context settlement
hierarchy then please page 49 of the
PDF we have policy
S8 and if I look at paragraph 2.12 I see
the settlement hierarchy categories
don't
I yes and latchingdon was classified as
a smaller Village wasn't it it was yes
that that is essentially a matter of
planning judgment isn't it um it was
based on on evidence together with
planning judgment yes yeah um and if one
looks at
2104 it was a planning judgment
expressed against the evidence contained
in the third bullet point the molden
district rural offic facility survey
correct correct
yes and if I then look at compliance
with the development plan in that
context and just go back to policy
S1 so S1 on page
18 in the terms of um policy S12 the
most sustainable locations are the three
largest settlements aren't they
yes in terms of paragraph three that's
referring to development on previously
developed land and then the planned
growth at the Garden suburbs and the
allocations correct correct right so
what two and three are doing is
directing housing to allocations at the
three largest settlements isn't
it um yes or with in settlement
boundaries yes right now I'm going to
come back to this separately but
paragraph
12 paragraph 12 isn't precluding Green
Field development is it isn't it because
that would be inconsistent with the
framework correct it's not you're yes
you're correct yes and it's not I don't
think a no harm policy because that
would also be inconsistent with the
framework wouldn't it yes right so the
issue in paragraph 12 is whether
proposal has an unex acceptable impact
on the identity whatever that may be of
latchington
correct
yes and if I look next then please I'll
come to the substance of that towards
the end of the cross- examination but
policy S2 then
please this then we see in the first
paragraph is focusing development on the
district's three main settlements isn't
it yes and it's telling us in the third
paragraph that the majority of New
Growth will be developed through sues
correct yes that's correct and a
proportion of new development will be
directed to the rural villages to
support rural needs correct yes but
actually we we need really to read and
interpret and apply policy S2 and S8
together don't we uh with S7 as well
okay but there's no evidence to suggest
that this proposal will Prejudice the
delivery of the ldp in the terms of S2
is
there uh do you mean in terms of the the
further points and yeah there's there's
no evidence that any allocated site will
not deliver because of this proposal
point no thank
you and so then if I look at policy S8
then
please
what the policy in S8 is doing page 49
is restricting to vitment to sites
within settlement boundaries isn't
it no it's saying which development what
types of development can happen outside
of settlement boundaries okay let's put
it this way outside settlement
boundaries there can be no harm to the
intrinsic character and beauty of the
open Countryside correct correct and you
need to meet one of the Criterion
correct yes correct right and so this is
a no harm policy isn't it no harm to the
intrinsic character and Beauty yeah well
it's saying in
principle this type of development
shouldn't happen regardless of whether
there's harm or not yeah and and that
approach that was the approach of PPS 7
and not the nppf in what we now see
paragraph 180a and 180b isn't
it um no harm to the character and
beauty of the open Countryside was the
PPS 7 approach it's not the approach of
the mppf 2012 or the latest version of
the mppf is
it I'd need to go back and and and read
that to make sure but I I as I said I'm
I'm comfortable that this policy
approach remains consistent with the
mppf and it was found to be so and of
the
examination okay well I I I'll perhaps
touch on that again a bit later and pick
it up with Mr Armstrong if you're if
you're not sure what PPS 7 was saying um
it's impossible for Market housing to
comply with policy ID unless it's
allocated isn't
it um it or within a neighborhood plan
yes yes which again is an allocation it
is an allocation yeah yeah so it's then
it also follows then that it is
impossible for a mixed market and
affordable housing scheme to comply with
policy S8 isn't
it there are a number of elements of S8
that could involve forms of residential
development um
I don't think yeah I think you're
correct I don't think that yeah a
residential lead scheme Market
residential lead scheme would not comply
and that ignore the first part that
second part a market a mixed market and
affordable scheme can't comply that's a
purely spatial
restriction uninfluenced by a
consideration of the merits or the
impacts of a proposal isn't
it that's the spatial strategy approach
yes and so we can agree then in in
concluding and agreeing that there's
conflict with the development plan
there's no requirement or scope to
consider
the need for Market housing is
there sorry can you can you repeat that
yeah so we've gone through let's just
look at S8 in isolation I conclude that
there's conflict with S8 and in doing
that I do that without considering
whether there's a need for Market
housing don't I yes uh
without considering the need for
affordable housing as well correct yes
without considering the affordability of
housing correct without considering the
need for specialist accommodation for
older people correct without considering
economic benefits correct without
considering the accessibility of the
site or the sustainability of the
settlement correct without considering
the actual landscape and visual impact
or the acceptability of it correct or
considering any form of planning balance
at
all that's correct but I would point you
towards policy seven which does allow
for those considerations through the
purposes of a neighborhood plan to make
allocations outside of settlement
boundaries okay well there's no conflict
with S7 and we're not in a neighborhood
plan it it is what I might reasonably
characterize as a computer says no
approach to development management isn't
it I wouldn't agree with that I think um
it's it's saying in principle how a
proposal of this nature is not going to
be acceptable outside of the boundaries
okay and the reason for that is because
at the time it wasn't considered that
there was a need it's that
straightforward there wasn't a need for
additional housing and there are also
considerable constraints so there are
risks to so let how much housing can be
planned let's look then next please at
the performance or the relative success
of that spatial strategy could you pick
up please the appendix to Mr Armstrong
appendix
one any if you could find please sorry
Mr
Armstrong separately bound appendices
yeah have you got that
yeah
and yes thank you and you've done what I
always do so which is to stick a posit
note in it and then that shows that
you've read it put a stamp a couple of
coffee marks
on um okay so I I just want to
interrogate really the performance of
the spatial strategy then in in the
context of the agreement we've
reached and if you could find please
um M mine's got page 10 and Page 15 on
it I'm not sure why but if you could
find page 10 and
15 so section five so it's the technical
name numbered these actually different
appendices we're looking at one
one SE page 10 I
think it's section five
section three oh we'll keep going so
then it's then it's black page 15 if
that I think because you've got the
intern you've got the internal one and
you've got Mr Armstrongs but at least
we' got some numbers which better than
normal um okay well I'll go by the black
numbers because In fairness to Mr
Armstrong I think that they go
continuously through so we're on page 15
yes please and what we note from 51 is
that at the EIP The Authority claimed a
5year supply didn't it yes correct but
but what we see from 52 is that very
quickly it became clear that the
authority couldn't demonstrate a 5-year
Supply didn't it yes because April 2020
4.9 years April 2021 3.26 years April
20122 3.66 years correct yeah so it's
three three years afterwards after the
approval
and if we look at the completions
please um which is table
4.1 so just go back a couple of pages to
page 11 and these are agreed in the
statement of common ground but I just
want to try and stick in one document if
I
can what we
saw in the first five years of the plan
so table 4.1 in the first 5 years of the
plan to 2019 was a 536 unit shortfall
correct
correct and as you went through with my
learned friend we now
have9 unit shortfall against the minimum
housing requirement of the plan correct
correct and what one sees at
4.2 is is that against the
trajectory a shortfall of 914 units
correct uh yes correct which is broadly
equivalent to three full year Supply
isn't
it broadly yes and that's a very
significant shortfall against the plan
trajectory against a minimum requirement
isn't
it um I think you need to look at the
109 figure rather than the cumulative
you look at how the plan is performing
as a whole um the trajectory is is
important but the longer you move away
from adoption or approval the less
Reliance you can have on individual
years of an individual planning um a
housing trajectory I would
say okay now the reason for the
significant shortfall is because of a
significant failure in the allocations
to deliverers claimed isn't it uh in
part yes but I think that's caused in
part by a global pandemic amongst other
issues well if we look at table
4.3 we see don't we I mean one has to be
fair Ju Just just go back I'm not really
sure this new point was raised by the
council and picked up by you we're
talking about the pandemic what from
sort of March 2020 it's not a new point
it was in my um statement of CAS okay
but the pandemic starting when March
2020 around then have I got my dates
correct uh yeah correct okay so up until
March
2020 just go back to table
4.1 what we see in fact is a failure to
deliver against the minimum housing
requirement in five out of the first six
years don't we yes but the examination
was ongoing for four of those first five
years yes which if I may say so makes it
all the more extraordinary that the
trajectory has been so violently a skew
when from 2017 you're 332 units out and
then 2019 192 units out because you're
only predicting 24 months in advance
aren't
you sorry I don't I don't understand
that point okay just just go back to
table
4.3 the reason for for the significant
shortfall is because of the significant
failure in the allocations to deliver as
projected correct or as planned yes it's
they haven't delivered as planned
correct and there is an agreed table 4.3
910 unit shortfall against the allocated
sites isn't
there um in terms of their specific
individual trajectories yes right and
then if I look please
at table
4.4 what you have then pointed out to
the inspector in your examination in
Chief is Haha but performance has
improved more recently correct correct
right um what we see in fact then over
the last 5 years is 633 units being
granted on windfall sites don't we
correct that's 32% of the total
completions isn't it uh I believe that's
correct yes right right and so if one
looks at
4.6 what we see is there was a planned
windfall allowance of 23 dwellings panum
but in fact an average delivery of 127
dwellings on windfall sites correct
correct right and that includes Green
Field sites outside settlement
boundaries doesn't it it does because of
the Tilted balance being applied yeah
and so what we can agree is that the
plan
has significantly failed to deliver the
minimum number of required houses as
planned hasn't
it uh yes but that I would I would
strongly suggest that global economic
conditions have had a significant role
in in that not the only reason but worth
significant reason for
that it's very helpful thank you now
what we know then is that there's a
statutory and National policy
requirement to review the plan every 5
years isn't there yes there is and just
turn up please the statement of Common
Ground so this is the main statement of
common
ground at
7.9
um do do you have that electronically
sir we'll just get that electronically I
think I had a Pap copy of the housing
Land one but not the so so that is CD
9.3
c93 thank you and if you could find
Please Mr Coleman page
15 paragraph
7.9
yes and if you just read 7.9 and foot
Note 3 it's agreed that the council has
carried out a review and determined that
an update is required hasn't it uh yes
and that's what's meant by update is a
statutory update in accordance with the
terms of the planning and compulsory
Purchase Act 2004 correct yes so that's
a statutory process isn't it
yes and if you turn please to CD
5.9 CD
5.9 sorry which which what's the it's a
technical briefing paper to the overview
and scrutiny
committee CD 5.9 yes please CD
5.9
because I want to examine and try and
agree with you the reasons for the need
for an update to the
plan
sorry just bear with me a second so this
is this is the overview and scrutiny
correct sir thank
you this is fiveyear housing land Supply
paper yeah so it's a technical briefing
paper from the authorities lead planning
policy officer to the authorities
overview and scrutiny committee d dated
July 2022 isn't
it sorry I'm struggling to find
that okay everyone got
it and if one finds please sorry just b
a
minute
does everyone have it sorry I I've got
it I'm just waiting on Mr
colaner a laptop oh is
the no just trying to find the document
sorry okay sorry I have that yes have
you got it and and if you just look at
1.1 what what
essentially the officer is interrogating
is why there's been a failure to deliver
sufficient homes to meet the
government's minimum requirement for a
5year supply what's proposed to resolve
the difficulty and what the impact is on
the local development plan and the
impending review correct correct
and if one looks at 5.1 please we see
the trajectory set out don't we yes at
5.2
please and could you find the second
paragraph in the bullet point that
begins however the trajectory was
nevertheless ambitious yes do you see
that yeah so there's a recognition that
the trajectory was ambitious yes and and
next bullet point point that one of the
sites at least should be removed
correct are you with me I am I'm just
reading it
sorry what it says if the examination
were happening now it is probable that
the site would be removed by the
inspector but that's the officer's view
yeah just so I'm clear on this document
I can't see a date on uh I said July
2022 July
2022 so this was I mean just as appendix
a briefing over the
committee um there doesn't there doesn't
seem to be any date on it
but unless I'm missing
it that's right Mr um then I'll take
your word uh well I I don't want to give
evidence but nor do I tend to
nor nor do I just tend to completely
make stuff
up so can we try and just resolve that
outside the inquiry uh yeah I mean I
just wanted to be clear that obviously
these comments that are being made about
difficulties and you know the context
of difficulty and so I just wanted to be
clear I'm not sure
what what's that I
wonder yeah but whose
laptop the streaming Works through a
laptop oh I see sounds like somebody's
unplugged it if it's making so where I
think I've taken that from is if you
find Mr Armstrong's evidence yeah page
19 and um fa note
14 that's got the date of 28th of July
2022 on
it so we're looking at page 18 19 Mr
Armstrong right okay and that's that's
the 28th of July 2022 yeah
okay okay fine thank you I I mean I
assume that's correct uh if Mr Armstrong
has I've have no reason to say that
that's not the correct
date so these comments relate to this
the situation in 2022 then the the
correct paragraph 1.1 yeah
thanks okay and and and so what what
then just looked at that 5.1 it sets out
the trajectory yes 5.2 comment about the
trajectory being
ambitious and then if one looks at
5.4 we see uh at that time the Strategic
sites have delivered 32% of their
housing trajectory which left a
shortfall of 67% or approximately 919
homes and we've looked at the updated
position correct correct okay and then
if we just look
at um the
problems uh the officer is saying ldp
should be flexible enough to accommodate
additional housing growth if it's needed
to come forward in between reviewing
plans this is called windfall Housing
Development and it should feed the
supply with extra housing when needed
alongside the slower pace of deliv of
the Strategic sites there are several
other contributing factors to the
council not having a 5-year housing
Supply and those factors are set out but
the essential
recognition or diagnosis is that the
plan is inflexible or not adequately
flexible is that
fair um that was that officer's view
reflected it's not a view I share but um
that's their view but we're then told
that there are several several other
contributing factors the first is that
there was no policy setting out how the
windfall allowance would be delivered
correct can I just ask where you are in
the document sorry I can't see so
55 yes and that talks about several
other contributing factors and then the
first contributing factor is in the
first bullet point okay and it says
there was no policy setting out how the
windfall allowance was be delivered and
that's right there is no policy setting
out how the windfall allowance would be
delivered was there I'm not aware of
there being policies in no certainly not
local plans I've been involved in which
which have a policy of that nature and I
I would like to also just say again that
the windfall allowance and the neighbor
plan allowance was largely used up just
before the examination had concluded
which is why the numbers are quite
relatively low okay the the next Point
that's made is that the policies are not
written very clearly compared to more
recent local plans they may have many
constraining caveats which are repeated
throughout the ldp making it difficult
for developers to gain planning
permission that's the second point isn't
it uh again that's the officer's view
it's not one I agree with at all uh the
third point
is the settlement
boundaries effectively squeeze out
nearby opportunities for windfall
development within those boundaries or
just outside and any other Housing
Development is generally refused as
being in the open Countryside this is
even when it's adjacent to existing
settlements and could be considered
acceptable in all other consideration so
what the offic is saying is we're having
problems here because of an
inflexibility in the application of the
settlement boundary policy which is
having the effect of refusing otherwise
sustainable proposals correct that's
what the yes essentially that's what the
officer is saying I again I don't agree
with the the statement uh and then it
said that the settlement hierarchy was
based on out ofd uh evidence and
evidence which wasn't robust because
there were no site visits and the
evidence simply came from the parish
council and the effect of that is that
applications are being refused in
settlements which could now be
considered to be sustainable correct um
again that's what it says but I don't
agree with that position I think it's
fundamentally actually Incorrect and
then lastly it's saying uh all of this
means bringing forward any development
outside the Strategic sites is difficult
correct yes and
nowhere does the officer trying to give
a robust independent objective
analysis of why the supply at that point
was problematic and there was no 5year
Supply referred to recessionary factors
or the pandemic or any of those issues
correct um again yes correct but I don't
agree with their analysis right
um next please in terms then of what is
proposed in this
report we're told that there are several
actions that the council can take to
resolve and one of them was to carry out
a review of the ldp and allocate
additional housing wasn't it yes where
are you sorry in the document so
paragraph
8.1 okay yes so so the first was to
carry out a review and allocate
additional housing yeah yes and if you
look then at the the fifth
point that was to ensure that the
policies in the reviewed ldp are less
constrained more positively written for
housing growth and flexible in line with
the updated National policy so
effectively what the officer is saying
is don't have what I've characterized
and you've disagreed with as this
computer says no approach where you have
mixed market and affordable housing
outside settlement boundaries and just
say no to them it's saying that you
should have more positively written
policies for housing growth correct uh
that's what the officer is saying again
I don't agree with it but that's their
view
no so what I want to do then uh next
please is look at the material
considerations and it might be that
that's a logical place for a break so
sir I've done my bit on the development
plan and how the development plan is
done and uh what the council have said
about that and now I'm going to move on
to the material considerations that we
say outweigh that agreed conflict so if
that's clear where everyone is that
might be an appropriate Point
yes to um to to to break uh I mean in
terms of your progress Mr K halfway
through about halfway through don't
like yes yes well I mean uh I think
um we've been going Mr colan took the
was started his cross examination
shortly after two wasn't it just after
two so you're not I think you're doing
quite well really it's only well
instruct me to make a
not in terms of speed yes um no I mean I
I didn't I didn't I didn't mean anything
anything derogatory Mr kuk um I I I mean
no
I was meaning you're sticking to your
timetable I I I don't comment on on on
these matters um anyway yeah no that
sounds like a good idea let's break I
don't know whether this will I'm on
support ready yeah excellent um so if we
break let's have uh let's come back
about uh shall we say we'll come back at
quarter past 3 is that okay we we'll
adjourn until quarter past 3 uh
obviously you can't discuss your
evidence with anyone thank
you
thank you very very much um we will
resume the public inquiry um and uh Mr
kuk was uh Midway way through his
cross-examination of the council's
witness uh Mr Coleman so I'll allow uh
Mr canuk to continue with his cross-
examination thank you thank you very
much sir so material considerations the
first one then the the need for Market
housing um we agree that there's a 5year
supply of 5.97 years don't we yes um a
5-year Supply is the minimum requirement
of the framework against a minimum
housing requirement isn't it yes correct
and we agree the local housing need
figure using the standard method is 279
dwellings per atom don't we yes and
that's lower than the extant annualized
requirement of 310 dwellings perom which
is required to be the minimum
requirement for minimum economic growth
correct um yes but objectively say needs
yes okay and so then um if I could ask
you to go back to the technical note Mr
Armstrong's appendix one and find table
5.3 on page 21 so page 21 Mr Armstrong
appendix
one and if I ask you to find in table
three we we had what was the council's
position and the appellant's position
and now we we've agreed the appellant's
position so the 5year supply is 1665
correct yes correct and if we look at
5.33 of that
1665 620 dwellings are on windfall sites
correct um using yes based on uh Mr
Armstrong's information yes yeah and
that that is
is
37% of
1665 so the windfall sites are
37% of the future Supply
correct it says 33% here but yes well I
think that that's because of the the
council Supply if you look at foot Note
5 that's 620 of 1861 is 33% if you do
620 of 1665 it's
37% yes and and what we see at 533 is
without the windfall Supply actually it
would be 4.45 years
correct uh according to this yes yeah
okay and so then if I look at table
5.4 what we see is that of those
620 417 are on large nine large sites
aren't they
yes and if you turn on to page
535 we see that eight of those nine
large sites are outside the settlement
boundary correct yes and we've got 405
dwellings on large windfall sites on
Greenfield sites in addition to 118
dwellings on 71 small windfall sites
located outside the settlement
boundaries so what we know is there are
a total of
523 dwellings on windfall sites outside
settlement boundaries do you agree that
I agree that's what it says yes
absolutely it sounds it sounds right
yeah so we've got 31%
effectively in the 5year supply which
are contrary to the development
plan and what we know also at
536 is that uh in one case the Secretary
of State
granted consent when a 5-year Supply
could be demonstrated
correct
uh I
536 yes I wasn't aware of that but yes
according to this yes so what we can
agree is that the local Authority can
only demonstrate a minimum 5year Supply
against a minimum housing requirement
because of a very significant proportion
of homes being consented on Green Field
sites outside the settlement boundary
contrary to the SP strategy of the plan
can't we uh because the yes because the
Tilted balance was applied for a number
of years hence schemes coming forward on
windfall sites um as I have stated I
believe that there was um a number of
factors restricting the Strategic
allocations which has led to them not
delivering as anticipated but they are
now delivering at significant speed
right well you say significant speed
that they're delivering up 1665 that's
what's projected for the next 5 years
yeah that's
agreed uh yes in terms of that Quantum
yes yes okay so what we can see though
from table 5.5 which is then the future
5e Supply
position we see that the housing Supply
is set to fall based even on the
Authority's flawed trajectory
correct that's that's what this that's
what the table says I'm not sure if
all the basis for the numbers
but what it's telling us at 540 is that
further windfall SES so that's Green
Field sites outside settlement
boundaries are going to be required if
the council is to maintain a minimum
5year Supply that's quite clear isn't it
and has been clear for the last 10
years um I it depends on the delivery of
the alloc Strategic allocations and
garden suburbs it certainly has been the
case histor ially but those sites should
be delivering higher numbers going
forward than they have historically okay
so let's break it down in this way that
has been the case and it will be the
case in the next 5 years
correct what will be sorry the the the
allocations delivering more or the sorry
it will be the case that the local
Authority will be dependent on Green
Field sites outside settlement
boundaries to have a minimum 5year
Supply not additional ones no not those
I'm not saying additional ones because
I'm breaking and then I'm going to look
at the future so what we've agreed so
far is the past we've agreed the 5-year
period And it being the case that it's
been the case in the past it's been the
case in the 5-year period and we see the
future 5e Supply the trajectory going
down 23 24 25 it follows that it will
remain the case in the future w't
it um I don't agree because I believe
that the allocations are already
increasing their delivery and will
continue to do so okay I see no evidence
to set against what's set out at table
5.5 do I no we haven't provided specific
evidence no okay so then um just in
terms then of the plan period Supply
turn over the page to
6.1 we have
agreed that there were
2,681 dwellings competed between 2014
and 2023 correct
correct and that leaves
1,969 to be delivered from 2023 to the
end of the plan period in 2029 to meet
the minimum requirement correct uh
correct right and so 1
1969 over 6 years that's 320 8 dwellings
per anom isn't it yes and if as we
know we've got a residual of
669 and we've got 1665 in the 5year
supply that leaves a residual of 34
units
correct
um yeah I obviously haven't got those
numbers but
yes thank
you and so I mean I will just put it
once but when the plan figure is a
minimum and the 5year supply is a
minimum
requirement it's unanswerable isn't it
that the benefits of delivering more
Market housing is a material
consideration of significant weight in
the context of an nppf imperative to
boost significantly the supply of new
homes isn't it no not at all costs well
I'm not saying at all costs I've got to
balance this against the conflict with
the development plan but look at it in
isolation that's where the Tilted
balance comes in I know I'm not asking
I'm about the weight just to be attached
to the benefits of delivering Market
housing if I've got an imperative to
boost significantly the supply and the
plan figures a minimum the 5year supply
is a minimum
requirement the benefits of delivering
more Market housing is a material
consideration of significant weight in
this case isn't it no I don't I don't
agree
next please the need for affordable
housing uh proposal of 160 homes 80 of
which will be affordable correct yes
correct and if I just ask you to turn
please to CD
3.1 and and Sir can I say when I get an
answer like that I feel like I've put my
point it's fairly simple point and
you'll be more than capable of making a
judgment and I'm not not going to waste
a lot of time bashing people over the
head and I'm assum you're just taking
that as red I I appreciate uh Mr kuk
that there's a degree of here endorse
your your your uh your there's no point
in spending a long time and then I'm not
no criticism of the witness either you
know I have to just make a judgment on
these things where there's a
disagreement you've got the evidence now
and and now that's the ultimate judgment
thank you so need for affordable housing
CD
3.1 uh policy
H1 on page 82 of the
PDF uh no that's not right sorry
apologies it's
uh it
I it's 82 of the hard copy as well is
it8 okay I don't quite how that's
changed but anyway there we go
uh yeah sorry H1 I was looking at the
wrong policy that's the that's sorry
right so policy H1 and if you look at
5.2
please the plan was identifying a
significant shortage in the availability
of affordable housing in 2014 wasn't it
yes and so an increase in the supply was
one of the key priorities wasn't it yes
and if one looks please at
we're then being told by the plan that
the delivery of future housing should
meet the needs and aspirations of people
requiring market and affordable housing
because that's a vital part of creating
sustainable communities correct correct
and the evidence base was the schar 2012
wasn't it correct now we can agree that
policy H1 doesn't set out an affordable
housing requirement as such does it no
it does not what it's doing is it's
trying to deliver a percentage of Market
homes as affordable homes correct
correct and if I just look at CD 316
please so the inspector's report CD
316 and could you find please paragraph
127 of the inspector's
report
what we see is the inspector identifying
a net need for affordable housing of 130
dwellings per anom correct correct
and we expected strategic allocations to
deliver around half of the affordable
units needed correct correct and it was
on that basis that the inspector had
some reasonable degre Dee of confidence
about the affordable housing figures
correct correct and then at paragraph
129 we see some other sources of
potential Supply but the contribution
from rural exception schemes was not
large correct correct and then if I look
at
130 the inspector concluded that there
was on that basis a reasonable prospect
that the need for affordable housing
could be met correct yes correct could
you pick up please is the evidence of Mr
Roberts and could you find please 5.8 on
page
and I'm doing this for convenience we
can go to the document if necessary but
I I I don't want to the 2014 schar
identified a need of 201 affordable
homes 2014 to 2019 didn't
it um yes why but are you going to
explain the difference in the yes and
then and then it was 149 over 15 years
and the difference between the two
figures was a difference depending on
how quickly the backlog was cleared
correct correct yeah and then the 130
figure referred to by the inspector
didn't take account of the backlog
correct as I understand it yes brilliant
so then next please the the
latest objective evidence is from the
council's local housing needs assessment
may 2021 isn't it correct and if you
turn please to
that is setting out so
519 that's setting out uh a need of 174
social affordable rented homes per
anom uh and then 35 affordable homes for
ownership a total of 209 affordable
homes per anom 2020 to 2040 correct
correct and that's
4,180 homes over a 20-year period isn't
it yes and if one look at
521 in that context the council's
housing needs assessment acknowledged a
notable need for affordable housing
correct
correct uh and also that it was an
important and pressing issue and that
therefore housing delivery should be
maximized where opportunities arise
correct correct and the reality is that
this need will be met on viable Green
Field Market home
sites because there's limited scope for
res schemes correct uh no I don't agree
well how else is it going to be met
other than on viable Green Field sites
through Market homes
delivery um through the allocations in
the plan together with whatever the
council decides to do in the future
through its ldp
review so allocations and ldp review
through the ldp review it is
unanswerable that this local Authority
will be significantly dependent on
Greenfield sites outside settlement
boundaries won't it well it's inevitable
that there will be new further
allocations required in the future yes
but that's that's for the council to
determine right
understood um in terms of delivery could
you turn to Mr Roberts figure
6.1
so figure 6.1 it's page
25 we see a total do you see the middle
column sorry so figure 6.1 page 25 uh
page
25 we see a total of
581 additions in the plan period don't
we yes and that's an average of 65 net
per anom isn't it uh yes it is which is
less than half the need for 154 correct
uh correct right and then at figure
6.2 we see in respect of affordable
housing delivery so table figure 6.2 on
page 26 I see significant shortfalls
annually don't I
um not always significant but certainly
shortfalls yes and a very significant
cumulative shortfall don't I yes and uh
a shortfall of 805 units that's over
five years Supply that shortfall is very
significant isn't
it yes but it needs to be also
considered in a national context of a
shortage of affordable housing um a
crisis nationally so yes I don't I don't
say it isn't significant but it is a
also a national trend
for affordable housing to be affordable
housing need to be growing and
shortfalls to be
growing okay I'm not going to fence with
you I mean it doesn't it doesn't become
less significant just because it might
be worse elsewhere does it no it doesn't
no okay so then um what I
see then please if one looks at figure
6.3 self-evidently I see that
performance is
worse against the assessment of 2021
correct and I see a shortfall of 305
occurring in just 3 years so around 50%
of the need again
correct where are you referring to sorry
so sorry figure six .3 on page
27 this is then an assessment against
the
2021 lnh so against the figure of
209 I see a total shortfall of 305 do
you see that yes okay and so that's
about
50% of the most recently identified need
being delivered
correct the shortfall since 2020 isot is
uh 50% sorry say that again yeah so the
lnh set out an annual need of 209
yeah uh so that's
627 the the shortfall has been
305 so effectively it's been running at
about
50% of that need
correct uh using those figures yes um
but it the the offer does does
acknowledge that delivery is improving
and has improved since
2019 I'm not suggesting that there isn't
a shortfall but there's a positive trend
well not sure that's quite true if you
look at the additions
20121 127
94101 an average of
107 anyway it's fair to conclude looking
at those figures that the delivery of
affordable housing in the plan period
has been abject hasn't
it I wouldn't use the word abject I
would say that I would certainly agree
that
um there is a considerable need for
affordable housing I would also suggest
that that is something that the plan is
if you like doing its best to try and
address I think the scale of need is is
considerable and as I've said I think
that's something that certainly I see in
my work across the country um is a
patent which is sadly being being seen
in many local authorities but I do see
um as the author of the report suggests
that there is an upward Trend um which I
would say is correlated with in my
opinion the allocations in the plan
starting to now deliver at the pace um
that is anticipated or more closer to
the PACE that's anticipated well let's
have a look at that Mr Robert's 7.7
please on page 32
from the council's own estimates there's
a supply of 499
homes which is an average of well it's
an average of 98
actually yeah sorry which figures do you
say so
7.7 yeah okay so the council is saying
it will deliver 499 affordable homes
over the next 5 years yeah so if I
divide 499 by 5 I get 98 affordable
homes perom yes yeah correct Which is
less than half of the need identified in
the 2021 assessment isn't it yes so it's
not doing any better in the next 5 years
either is it not according to those
figures no no well the council's own
figures I mean they're not my figures
right and so if I look at
figure 7.1 please over the page on page
we see that the shortfall will increase
from
805 which you agreed was very
significant to over a thousand units
with one year of the plan period to go
correct correct right and so
respectfully the EIP inspector's
confidence was misplaced wasn't
it he said that I believe the use the
words re reasonable Prospect didn't he
yeah um
um I think that was his judgment to make
at the time and as I said this it's it's
not as straightforward as just saying
the plan has failed there are a number
of reasons why affordable housing
delivery is not at the level it it
ideally should be um and the scale of
affordable housing need is such in this
district and in many areas that it's
very difficult for a local plan to clear
shortfalls through
require requiring Market housing to
provide affordable housing and let's be
clear the only reason why it's able to
deliver
499 affordable homes in the next 5 years
is because of that component in part of
Green Field sites outside settlement
boundaries isn't it in part yes yeah and
so you would
agree that with one year of the plan a
shortfall of a thousand affordable homes
demonstrates that the plan has failed as
planned to
deliver what it said it would deliver at
the EIP I mean that's unanswerable isn't
it well it certainly hasn't achieved the
levels that were anticipated that's
correct okay and then just in in moving
the debate on to affordability if you
look at
8.3 we see 981 households on the
affordable register don't we yes each
one of those represents a family in
urgent need doesn't it yes and if I look
at figure
8.3
where properties are becoming available
I see bids of 50 to one or 101 to one
for one to two bed homes don't
I uh think or 8.3 yes and if I look at
836 I then see affordability ratios of
11.67 don't I
yes and that means in the real world
that housing is unaffordable for a very
significant proportion of the local
population doesn't it it does although
figure forgive me but fig figure
8.1 does also show that whilst the
housing register households on the
housing register are very substantial
and I don't underestimate that at all
the number has decreased
slightly which could reflect I suggest
could reflect a an improvement
appreciate that that's that's I I think
Mr Roberts would explain it's a
difference in the reporting but anyway I
won't I won't get hung up on that if you
look at
9.88 uh sorry uh if you just go back
please to
8.36 so 8.36 on page
41 so the affordability ratio is
11.67 and that's an 18% increase since
the start of the ldp period in 2014 and
so what we are seeing is as a result of
the failure to deliver market and
affordable homes prices are increasing
aren't
they uh they are increasing um I don't
have the obviously the figures um to
compare that to the the national
Trend um but it yeah I mean the fact is
the number of homes coming forward in
this district is much higher now than it
has been historically orbe it it's still
yeah there's still an affordability
issue of course yes if your point is
that green field sites outside
settlement boundaries are boosting your
supply we agree uh I if you turn please
to 3.4 on page
seven so 3.4 on page seven what what we
are seeing now is that the first time
buer ages have crept up to
40 yeah
yes and it's characterized and you would
agree with this characterization
nationally and locally wouldn't you if
you look at 3.3 that the delivery of
affordable housing is in crisis isn't it
yes and essentially local planning
authorities have broken the social
contract with its local population that
if you work hard you can afford your own
home that's what's happened hasn't it I
wouldn't label that entirely at local
authorities door to be
honest I don't think that's um that's a
fair characterization but okay but the
consequences are if one looks at 426
please the council has failed its own
corporate priority hasn't
it um I wouldn't use the word failed
because I think as I said there are a
number of factors that feed in here and
I think what the council is tried to do
through the ldp the local development
plan is to substantially increase the
supply and it hasn't increased as much
as it was anticipated but it has
increased Beyond historic levels and if
one looks at 318 please what we actually
see is that the affordability of housing
is the main cause of homelessness isn't
it
yes and at
313 so at the top of page N9 we're now
finding that over half of homeless
families are in work aren't they yes and
so if one looks please at
321 it's correct isn't it that the only
way to end the affordability the
affordable housing crisis is is to build
more social housing isn't it
yes and you'd agree that the delivery of
80 homes is a benefit of substantial
weight wouldn't you I would yes thirdly
please the need for specialist
accommodation for older
people um 10% are proposed as Bungalows
aren't they yes if you turn please to Mr
Armstrong's
evidence his main proof at
so 524 Mr Armstrong page
40 the pp G characterizes the need to
provide housing for older people as
critical doesn't it yes and and I don't
note any calibration higher than
critical do I in National policy or
national
guidance I'm not aware of a sort
of higher imperative for you that's not
not um something I'm I yeah I I I I
agree but I don't know sure and the
reason it's critical is because of what
we call the demographic Time Bomb
correct yes and um if I ask you then to
look at CD
4.2 so CD
4.2 and this is the authorities
specialist needs housing SPD September
yeah um and what I see if you could turn
to paragraph
1.2 on page 4 of 58 on the
PDF
yeah I see that six 67% of the projected
growth of the district's population over
the next 15 years will be people aged 65
and over correct correct and it's
considered then in this council's SPD to
be a priority to ensure that the future
supply of homes meets the housing needs
of this group correct correct and so
what we see is that that National
demographic Time Bomb has a local
expression in molden doesn't it yes and
if I ask you to turn to paragraph
1.4 the council's SPD is then telling
decision makers that providing a wider
choice of specialist needs uh and
housing options better suited to their
requirements is is important correct
correct and at
3.10 so if you could scroll through to
3.10 on page
the SPD is then telling us that it's
essential that the district's housing
market operates
cohesively because what happens is if
older people downsize into say Bungalows
then that frees up underutilized family
homes and each downsizer then triggers
three further moves and releases starter
homes correct correct and in that
context if you turn to 225
please
it's characterized in that paragraph as
an acute need for specialist housing in
the district isn't it yes and if one
looks at
226 and the final bullet point of
226 it's telling us that Bungalows could
help meet the needs of both older people
and those with specialist needs but
these are not as readily available in
general housing stock and often more
expensive due to their limited
availability so we can agree that the
benefit of delivering 16 Bungalows
capable of meeting the acute need for
specialist accommodation for older
people is a material consideration of
significant weight isn't
it um it it's certainly um a benefit
offered by the The Proposal
absolutely of significant
weight I mean Mr Co I'm a little
different as to to to to what you want
to say it is because the inspector will
form his own view but for reasons I've
articulated I trust tolerably clearly I
say significant weight what do you say I
I certainly say
um very difficult to to to say for sure
but I mean yes absolutely of
weight
um I would say of moderate rate weight
there are other ways other than
Bungalows I'm not suggesting they're not
important but they are not the only
answer um next then please uh could you
pick up the statement of common ground
at
8.2 so the statement of common ground at
8.2
uh Sor that that's CD 9.3 uh sorry yes
let me get that for you
yeah I forgot to say because I've got
I've got it in hard
copy it is CD
9.3 I'm sorry which paragraph paragraph
8.2 on page 8
and so it's common ground that
latchingdon is an established Village
offering a number of services and
Facilities isn't it yes and it's agreed
that these facilities are all accessible
by by Fort cycle and public transport
correct yes and then um in terms of the
sustainability of the settlement could
you turn to CD
5.6 so CD 5.6 so this is the rural
facilities survey in settlement pattern
may
okay and if you just turn to paragraph
1.3 the context for this updated
facilities and settlement hierarchy
study was deficiencies in the previous
analysis which you don't accept
correct it doesn't say that here does it
well what what we saw is the technical
review is saying that effectively no one
went out on site wasn't very accurate
based on information from the parish
council and so what 1.3 is saying is
well look this is a much more
comprehensive analysis of the
settlements in the district
yeah again this is what that's saying um
I was I oversaw the original work and it
wasn't only information from the parish
councils so this is factually incorrect
okay um but yes that's what it says here
but
let's just think about this where I have
an analysis from 2012 where the council
itself is saying it's deficient and then
I have an updated document from the
council itself addressing in part those
deficiencies and it's claiming to be a
much more comprehensive analysis where
those two objective analyses conflict
it's reasonable isn't it to attach
greater weight to this
assessment um I haven't interrogated
this assessment but yes of course this
is a more upto-date piece of evidence
and obviously things have changed since
the last bit of evidence was done and
it's an objective assessment and it's
intended to form a robust basis for
decision making isn't it uh
yes and if I look please at
4.1 uh page seven of
this 4.1 page seven sir
conclusion of the rural facility study
yeah have you got it and what that's
telling me is that it's concluding that
the settlements have reasonable
connectivity to the higher order
settlements isn't
it um that's what it says I don't know
which settlements it's referring to well
molden haybridge and burnam on Crouch
Southwood and ferah with them and tip
tree
okay the settlements of the district
being Villages and then if you turn on
please to
5.7 and it's in the table on page 11 of
14 yes I see a definition of large
Village don't I you do yes and if I look
at 5.8
please what has been undertaken is an
exercise which which creates a
settlement pattern in what is called a
policy off Baseline for the local plan
review correct correct so this is a
policy off Baseline intended to be a
robust basis for future decision making
isn't it uh I I said I haven't
interrogated the document but I believe
so yeah and so if I look at 5.10 then
what it is
doing is concluding that against that
updated definition latchingdon is a
large Village
correct uh that is what the study is
suggesting was BW
open
um okay so yes I I think we agree Mr
Coleman that the conclusion of this
objective analysis is that latchingdon
falls to be considered as a large
Village correct um that's what the study
is is saying but I would highlight that
when you undertake these types of
exercises and produce this type of
evidence it obviously depends upon a
whole host of issues including the
criteria that you use to measure for
instance accessibility
um
and I don't suggest for a second that
there are inaccuracies in this work but
this has not been yet subject to
examination um there is you know the
older work you referred to um was
subject to
examination so yes this may well be the
direction of travel um I that's that's
absolutely the case but at the moment
this is just that
and you know things may change I'm not
sure what you mean by a direction of
travel we can draw a distinction can't
we between policy and evidence can't we
uh yes absolutely and this can be
afforded significant weight as a piece
of evidence can't we because it's
undertaken by the Council on an
objective basis to inform future
decision- making so it can be afforded
significant weight as a piece of
evidence not policy correct I don't it's
rare you I think you would afford
significant weight to to evidence it's
ing the policy production there may be
other um issues which are taken into
account which mean that the council do
not decide to um designate lingon as a
as a large Village sorry I'm not talking
about future policy I'm just talking
about latchington and its sustainability
and all I'm saying is this document has
provided council's document a definition
of larger settlement and latchington is
considered to be a larger settlement on
the basis of a 2023 analysis isn't it
yeah on the basis of the criteria that
they've decided to use yes and the
analysis that they've undertaken yes and
in fact on this analysis it's the fourth
most sustainable large Village isn't it
according to this analysis yes and if I
look then please at CD
5.2 CD
5.2 so this then is the reg
18 document the issues and options if
you find please page
22 so page
22 we see that the issues and options
document proposes to recategorize
latchington as a large Village doesn't
it uh yes um and it's reasonable to
attach limited weight to this as a piece
of policy isn't
it I I wouldn't
attach I
think it's reasonable to to attach
limited weight to it as as a piece of
evidence emerging as a piece of work
that's emerging but there are I've noted
the reason I hesitate is because there
are I have noted in my proof that there
are objections to this work um and to
this redesignation including from ESS
County Council um and that work is
clearly ongoing to look at this these
issues so very limited weight in terms
of the position that this sets out now
prior to further work being undertaken
the the objections that have been
received and then ultimately examination
so things as we all know can change
considerably but but what we know is the
council has undertaken an objective
analysis we've seen the conclusions and
then what we know has happened is the
reg 18 document has gone before members
to be approved before being published
for reg 18 consultation so the members
have decided that latchington should be
at this stage recategorized on the basis
of that evidence that's correct isn't
it I wasn't at the the meeting where
members de or decided that but yeah
technically they they have approved the
document for consultation that doesn't
mean that they won't necessarily change
their minds I don't know and if you turn
next please to CD 5.7 so CD
5.7 so CD 5.7 is the hear 2020 isn't it
uh sorry 2023 yes okay and the site was
examined as two parcels ld4 and ld6
wasn't
it um I believe so yes and if you turn
please to Mr Armstrong's evidence at
550 so Mr Armstrong's main proof at 550
on page
page so 550 so page
46 and the conclusions of the Heil
are were if you look at the the three
paragraphs in bold firstly that the site
was well located
correct well located in in the
settlement yeah next at 551 the
conclusion is that overall the site was
suitable wasn't it yes and 552 again no
Heritage assets which the development of
this site could harm subject to some
surface water flood risk could be
mitigated overall the site is suitable
depending on the access correct correct
okay so the hear supports the contention
that the site is accessible and adjacent
to a sustainable settlement doesn't it
um it doesn't say it's a sustainable
settlement it says it's a sustainable
location within the settlement or an
appropriate listen to the question the
heel art supports the conclusion that
the site is accessible and adjacent to a
sustainable settlement doesn't it
otherwise it wouldn't have been
considered
suitable
I would need to look at more detail in
the heila to answer that question I
don't the the the hear is looking at the
location of the site it's access to
services and facilities and any
designations in or around the site okay
it's not necessarily taking it as I
understand it and I could be wrong it's
not taking conclusion as to whether or
not each settlement is a sustainable
settlement okay uh the officer concluded
in terms that latchingdon was a
sustainable settlement didn't he which
officer sorry the officer in the report
the the reporting
officer sorry are we talking about the
officer in Rel which officer are we
talking about I'll take you to the
document so document CD
2.1 CD
2.1 so this is apologies this is the
committee report officer yeah I I see
yeah and if you find please paragraph
4.1.7 I I thought you meant that Mr yeah
no apologies so it's my
fault so at the end of 4.1.7 the officer
is concluding in terms that latchington
is a sustainable settlement correct um
that that was his assessment I I don't
agree with that assessment right um and
on the authorities case uh there's no
unacceptable Highway impact is there uh
no there isn't there's no infrastructure
impact which cannot be met by conditions
or 106 is there no
and so it follows
that this proposal derives very
significant weight from the social role
of sustainable development doesn't
it no well well it must do even on your
analysis because there's some benefit
from delivering Market homes there's a
substantial benefit from delivering
affordable homes so even on that basis
it's deriving collectively very
significant weight from the social role
of sustainable development that's
unanswerable from the social role yes
yes there is weight from from the social
in terms of the economic
role um the nppf at paragraph 85 could
you turn to
that 85 sir you'll be with
this significant weight should be placed
on the need to support economic growth
and
productivity taking these matters simply
there'll be investment in construction
consequent direct indirect and catalytic
economic benefits employment Mr
Armstrong tells us supporting 496 people
an Office hub of 100 square meters uh
and a very significant increase in local
spends when high streets are under
pressure that's a benefit of significant
weight in the terms of national policy
isn't
it
well I'm I'm not agreeing that
um it's a significant benefit um I know
that's your question but you're asking
me to look at the mppf
and analyze those benefits against it
not not really I I'm just trying to give
you some brief context because these
questions I think respectfully are very
simple uh and they're fairly routine at
this type of inquiry we know what
national policy is saying we know what
the economic benefits of The Proposal
are they're not contested in those
circumstances those economic benefits
should be afforded significant weight
shouldn't they yes thank
you next the environmental benefits
there are no adverse impacts in terms of
flooding noise air pollution or Heritage
are there no so then the public open
space please 4.25 hectares of the site
would be multifunctional public open
space wouldn't it yes that's 42% of the
site and if I ask you to turn please to
the appendices of Mr M
priest and this is the illustrative
master
plan
uh I think it's just the first appendix
I have it this iscape yes
sir and if we just look at this very
briefly the the open space because the
inspector can certainly read a plan
better than I can but what that 4.25
hectares of open space will deliver is
informal open space a kickabout Area
Youth provision allotments and two
children's play areas correct
yes and it's set out essentially all
along the central portion and the
eastern boundary isn't it it is and it
will be accessible to existing and
future occupiers won't it
yes and it will be managed and
maintained in perpetuity won't it uh yes
and again just looking briefly at the
nppf paragraph
96 so paragraph
96 um it's government policy to achieve
healthy inclusive and safe places isn't
it yes and to promote social
interactions yes and specifically high
quality public open space which
encourages active uses yes to enable and
support Healthy
Lifestyles so this level of provision is
strongly supported by the nppf isn't it
yes and if you turn please to CD
4.3 so CD
4.3 this is the green infrastructure
strategy SPD
okay
and uh this is an SPD which has gone
through consultation and adoption isn't
it yes sorry bear with me I'm just oh
apologies CD
4.3
okay um and if you find please table 2.1
on page
sorry just having a few problems hold
on uh and that's page 47 on the PDF page
43 of the internal
document and table
2.1 see the page there we
go sry PDF page
47 uh yes okay got
that and if you look at typology
National sorry the typology five down
natural and semi-natural green space yes
it says to investigate the potential to
create new accessible green spaces in or
around latchingdon doesn't it it
does uh it's unknown if we're meeting
the standards
and if I look at
leaps they're below standard aren't
they yes neeps are below standard yeah
and a lot wondering Mr kuk if you could
for the benefit of members of the public
well I know we use all these rather
peculiar terms but I just wonder whether
maybe you could just explain what yeah
you're putting me on the spot now a leap
a leap is a locally equipped area of
play so uh a relatively small type of
children's play provision with five
different play types including safer
surfaces that people will be familiar
with uh a neep is a a neighborhood
equipped area for play so that's
providing uh a multi-use games area or a
skate park with with a sort of minimum
activity zone of about a th000 square
meters that that sort of provision um
and we see then that allotments the
leaps and the kneps are all below
standard don't we yes so what I see then
is the provision provided by this
proposal is significantly above what is
required by policy isn't it
firstly yes and it's supported by the
council's own green infrastructure
SPD yes and that amount of open space
4.25 hectares publicly available in
perpetuity is a benefit of significant
weight isn't
it um I believe it's a benefit of
moderate weight because I don't disagree
that the Quantum of provision is is of
great benefit but it's also a question
of where that space is to be located
where
those um facilities are to be located uh
next please
BNG a consequence of the significant
areas of open space is a very
significant biodiversity net gain
correct correct and it's agreed in the
statement of common ground that it's a
very significant net gain isn't it
correct and so that then leaves with my
remaining time please the impact on the
character and appearance of the
area
uh could you turn please to the nppf 180
and
and we can agree simply that the site is
not internationally nationally or
locally designated is it no it's not
it's not a designated landscape is it no
it isn't it's not a valued landscape is
it no it isn't it has no statutory
status or identified quality in the
development plan does it no and it's not
protected then within the terms of
paragraph
18a correct uh correct and just to be
clear going back to a point probably
seems some time ago now policy
s112 that isn't the approach of policy
s112 is it to draw a distinction between
designated and non-designated sites
valued and non-v valued landscapes
no it's
not um and if I ask you to turn up
please the statement of Common
Ground so the statement of Common Ground
CD
9.3 and paragraph
we we see no objection is raised by the
authority on landscape grounds correct
correct and we agree that high quality
design can be delivered at the reserve
matter stage don't we yes and we agree
there's no impact on residential amenity
correct correct so that then leaves our
issue about policy
s112 and the issue there as we agreed
earlier is whether the proposal will
compromise the identity of lingon isn't
it yes and and to do that you have to
set out firstly the existing identity of
latchingdon don't you um sorry it's also
about maintaining the rural character of
The District then goes on to without
compromising the identity of the
settlement so it does have I think you
need to read the first part as well as
the second part well well let's let's
concentrate on the identity of
latchingdon
to to address that you have to consider
first the existing identity of
latchington don't you
um yes lington and the settlements of
the district okay you have to identify
something of some Merit or quality which
is worthy of protection don't
you uh not necessarily it's talking
about the identity of of the settlement
so it is what what it is that makes that
settlement as it is yeah but we agreed
previously it's not a no harm policy
it's not a no change policy policy isn't
it no it's not right so I have to
identify the identity of
lington and then having done that I have
to identify surely something of some
Merit or quality which I should be
seeking to preserve otherwise I'm
preserving everything correct well
you're preserving the identity the
identity is
not I appreciate not easy to
quantify certainly not something you can
scientific Al identify is it is the the
identity of the place of the settlement
yeah which is but but if if a settlement
was characterized by large areas of
industrial Wasteland that that wouldn't
be an identity that you would seek to
maintain would it no it would not no so
you're trying to identify aspects of its
identity which are of some Merit then
aren't
you yes I I I suppose you are although
that's not I appreciate that's not what
the policy say says um but I agree your
interpretation makes and then you have
to set out the impact on those positive
qualities of the identity don't
you no you're trying to you're trying to
scientifically um take apart the policy
wording I don't I don't think that's how
it's intended it's intended about to
it's intended to look at the overall
identity of the settlement which isn't
something you can I don't believe break
down into various components and nor
does the policy ask you to it's a
planning judgment based upon what will
compromise change for for the worse the
identity of that place there appears not
to be a disagreement between us that we
are not simply trying to preserve the
settlement it's not a no harm policy
it's not a no change policy okay we
agree that so if you if you're allowed
change and you're allowed
development you have to express a
planning judgment on whether you
compromise the identity okay so you can
have a change to the identity and you
can have harm to the
identity yes because it's not a no
change and a no harm policy so what that
must
mean is that you are trying to identify
what is worthy of protection the
positive qualities and then consider the
impact on those positive qualities which
is frankly the type of analysis one
undertakes in respect of all such
policies
correct um in yeah in general terms
absolutely and then you have to
understand whether that impact is
acceptable or unacceptable
correct I I I don't think it's a
scientific exercise in the way you're
you're breaking it down but no nor is a
judgment on
acceptability okay well if if you're
breaking it down in the way you're
suggesting
then then yes okay because if you just
pick up your evidence please can you
turn to your
[Applause]
4.10
so you're 4.10 on page
14 you say I am of the view that this
proposal would fundamentally alter the
rural character of the site and would
compromise the identity of latchington
yes that that is an assertion isn't it
that's my professional judgment yeah so
let's just look then at four 17 this is
where we get some
analysis again you're talking about the
change to the rural character and
identity of latchington and I want to
try and understand the points that
you're making to support that assertion
the first is a reference to designated
Heritage assets isn't
it yes right although I do indicate that
I'm not suggesting harm to the
designated Heritage so there's no harm
to their significance at all which means
that their special interest is preserved
correct correct right you then talk
about the core of the village the core
of the village will remain unchanged
won't it it will there's no harm to the
landmarks in that core is there uh no
and and as you've told us and
demonstrated visually there's
intervening modern Estates between the
core and the appeal site isn't there
there are right and and that setting of
modern housing to that Village core will
not change will
it no not for the existing development
no right so you then rely on the MDC
characterization
assessment and what this is setting out
at your
418 is that Villages have a nucleated or
linear
form respectfully that's not a very
helpful analysis is it because we only
tend to talk in two terms of settlement
forms they're either nuclear or
lineated well I think the the report
goes on to explain the linear nature of
the Agricultural settlements right but
what we have you see at
420 is the assessment was undertaken in
2006 yes and provides a high leval
analysis relating to a settlement type
rather than a bespoke analysis relating
to the appeal site or even latchingdon
yes so if I've got a 2006
analysis at a high level not of lington
but it's ignoring isn't it the
subsequent development that you yourself
told us has taken place since 2014 yes
right and which the local Authority
considered to be acceptable
correct uh some some of it yes
right okay but again sorry to interrupt
but that that would be under a different
some of it if not all of it I can't be
sure under a different context of a
tilted balance but your your your Appo
appears to be I'm not sure that we
accept in the inspector can form his own
view that there's a change to the linear
characteristic but my point is so what
unless you can demonstrate some
intrinsic Merit some quality that is
worthy of protection it doesn't take you
anywhere does it
why is it that one should protect a
linear characteristic as opposed to a
nuclear characteristic which is equally
characteristic my my point is that I was
trying to characterize the settlement to
give a sense of its historic
form and put that in the context of the
other settlement surrounding and the
other agricultural settlements of the
district which is important I I believe
for understanding the identity of those
settlements and whilst yes of course
there has been modern development which
has changed the nature of the
settlements it doesn't mean to say that
there should be more and my main point
is that development of this scale as I
said with such a significant increase in
the size of the village would I believe
fundamentally change the identity of the
of the village yeah look sorry the test
that we're looking at here is 12 of
policy S1 which which does I believe
require a planning judgment to be taken
it's not as I said it's not a as simple
as identify the any specific harms and
and weigh them up I just don't think
that's what it's asking you to do it's a
judgment call on is this proposal going
to alter and compromise the identity of
that settlement yeah look at your
421 so your 421 on page 17 what what
you're telling us is that the
development will create a modern housing
estate adjacent to other recently
developed residential uses aren't you
yes right that that suggests which Mr
milest agrees with that this part of
latchington has the identity of recently
developed residential uses doesn't
it um of a smaller scale and of a more
linear nature and it's fair to say that
that recently developed residential uses
has a relatively raw Urban Edge doesn't
it
uh leading up to the settlement boundary
yeah and so the development of more
housing won't change that identity at
all save that the modern housing will
extend slightly eastwards and it will
create a high quality interface with the
open Countryside correct no I believe
that the impact will be significant on
the settlement as a whole and it will
fundamentally change the
size
and type of develop um the the size and
nature of the
settlement um well sir I'll let you make
a judgment on that I'll pick it up with
Mr milre it's a fairly respectfully
simple point with which we disagree if I
just look at your table 4.22 though what
I see is that since
2014 162 new homes have been consented
correct
correct um and that tells me that
latchington is a sustainable location
for development doesn't it that that's
what the appeals decisions say in terms
don't they under the Tilted balance yeah
um it's not the same as uh I mean my
interpretation of what is a sustainable
settlement in the context of this
district is what's considered
sustainable by the the ldp and where
growth should be planned because it's
obviously a plan-led system and that's
what the council has taken a decision as
to
where which locations are most
sustainable for growth to meet the needs
okay and that's that's what that's what
the plan's for so we have 162 new homes
since 2014 and certainly then that part
of the settlement its identity is of
modern housing
correct uh the part shown in in
um yes on page 18 on the plan am I proof
and extending the builtup area does not
aat
axiomatically lead lead to policy
conflict does
it it does if it's beyond the settlement
boundary oh so it so it does in the
terms of
s112 extending the builtup area does not
axiomatically compromise the identity of
the village does it no it doesn't in
itself no and just in terms of some of
these figures then that you went through
in
Chief I just want to look at some of
your arithmetic please to the extent
that it's relevant and I'm not persuaded
that it is but anyway your uh
414 there were 4 91 dwellings
in 2011 correct households households
yeah and we then had I mean I'm sh well
it's difficult but 162 then new homes
yeah yes if we ass assume because this
is all broad Strokes that 491 households
are 491 houses because I think you've
said they're equivalent to one dwelling
yes that's so so that 162 is a 33%
increase isn't it uh yes to get to the
653 that 653 is the existing Baseline
isn't
it 65 that have been granted
consent sorry I've said 162 I meant I
meant 160 right so 160 is a third of 491
isn't
it broadly yeah yeah and then that that
651 that is the existing Baseline
against which to assess a change isn't
it um it's what's consented no obviously
not all of those have have been built
yet right and then the 160 on the appeal
side is
24.5% of the 650 isn't
it uh I'll Trust your mouse
okay because again I didn't really
understand respectfully what you were
telling my learning friend when you said
the appeal site is 10.12
hectares compared to the latchington
settlement boundary of 19 hectares but
that 19 hectare figure ignores all of
the modern development consented since
2014 doesn't it uh it does it's a
settlement made clear it's a settlement
boundary and it also ignores the 4.25
hectares of the appeal site that will be
open space doesn't it it
does
okay and so all that means then that
there's a judgment between us as to
whether the material considerations are
outweigh that agreed conflict with the
development plan I'm going to leave that
for the inspector thank you sir those
are my questions and thank you Mr
Coleman for helping me get that done
well within my estimate and I hope that
wasn't too turgid for everybody I'm sure
it wasn't uh Mr K thank you uh both of
you for for uh that that was uh most
helpful um I was wondering U Mr Wilcox
do you have much uh reexamination I I
have
about two minutes well that sounds uh
sounds good it's not my practice to
reexamine very often no no no no no well
go
ahead yes of course I I I have no
particular questions that I I wish to
put put uh to um the witness so if you
have any re-examination points that you
want to uh put I mean some of these
issues in terms of
character uh and you know the we were
talking about the urban Edge uh and so
on I mean these are matters that I can
form a view on um at my site
visit us talking no I mean I I don't
think there's a huge amount of point in
in discussing these things in in great
uh depth here because it is very much
something you can appreciate on site um
and and uh I think Mr kuk you know
explained his approach um
in in cross-examination that he was
essentially dealing with the development
plan first and then other material
considerations um that would weigh in
favor of allowing the proposal that was
the way you structured your sir um your
your your cross-examination so so that
that was that was helpful to have that
structured in that way so I I'll leave
it to you Mr Wilcox to ask any points
you want to uh make with I think thank
you sir and hello again Mr Colman it's
really only a single point and this
relates to my learning friend Mr K so
what question in respect of uh in
respect of the loss of the linear form
of lachend as a settlement and you
remember he asked you about well so what
if the linear forms lost and that
question was asked in the context of an
exercise in trying to identify aspects
of character or form that were and I
think his words were of Merit do you
remember that line of questioning I do
with that in mind can you uh please take
up once again core document
3.20 which is the characterization
assessment single reference I want to go
to when you've got it there please uh
it's hard copy page 61 PDF page 65 which
we been to already sir so this is 3
32 two 3.20 yeah and we've this is a
reference we've visited before sir you
remember we went to the specific
policies section within the
characterization assessment yeah yeah
and we we looked at some of those there
and when we look under 6.3 specific
policies the first thing we find is
policy 6.1 development form which tells
us the predominant linear form of the
settlement should be maintained and
closes and colder sacks should be
avoided uh Mr Coleman what if anything
does that tell the inspector about
whether or not the linear form of
settlement such as lendon is a feature
of Merit well absolutely is um the
evidence is suggesting that it is a
feature of Merit um and that it should
be should be
maintained um and that to maintain it
closes and cold act should be avoided um
it's their first
recommendation
um and that's that's specific to
agricultural
settlement thank you very much so that
was the only point I wanted to re except
up right um thank
you uh thank you as well of course to uh
Mr Coleman um for your uh forbearance
this afternoon so in fact that
effectively concludes the case for the
council doesn't it so that is the
council's case that is the council's
case so I'm just thinking about
tomorrow um well well so in sorry s
apologies for interrupting but um just
on that point having heard what's been
said today I don't consider a need to
call Mr Roberts so no no I think we are
I don't think anything has been thrown
up to I appreciate a couple of points
were taken by Mr Coleman but I I don't
think we need uh call him so so we've
got Mr milc first and and then Mr
Armstrong so Mr milc um first who will
deal with sort of character issues um
and then uh
Mr Armstrong of course
yeah I mean in terms of I think you you
you did give some indication of Chief I
think you were saying about 45 minutes
each was it I can't remember yes that
sounds like the sort of thing that I
would that I would that I would say
without giving it to
I think so if you were to work on that
basis I I might shave some off Mr milre
and possibly take maybe a little bit
longer with with um Mr Armstrong but I'm
going to reflect on the extent to which
now that we've done a lot of the heavy
lifting and and respectfully said
tomorrow I'm going to assume quite a lot
of inquiry knowledge um I I'll discuss
that with Mr Armstrong but I think it's
going to be of that order sir so and in
Cross um Mr wox how how long do you
think you might be uh so I I'd have
thought in the region of 45 minutes with
Mr milc maybe an hour perhaps closer to
two hours with Mr Armstrong maybe but I
think the upshot says we can comfortably
get through both Witnesses
tomorrow well that would be good if we
if we could um and then that would leave
Thursday for um Round Table discussion
and uh on conditions and
obligation
um in terms of I I mean obviously we
need to do a site visit as well but I'm
just thinking in terms of
closing uh your closings are um I know
certain bars like to have a bit of time
to prepare you know rather than doing I
I don't know what what your approach is
on on these things
um well s if I mean it depends what
progr press we make I mean I I I think
sometimes it
is bar are very good at pretending that
all of these things are really easy but
if you finish at sort of half five and
then you're expected to close at 10:00
it does make for uncomfortable evening
oh indeed indeed um I just just just
thinking ahead a little bit so if I may
just do it in my slightly pedestrian way
um I can I just ask where we are on
conditions and and the S compliance
statement because um and I don't know
what your practi is uh but if we do get
through and and we don't have a full day
tomorrow it might be if you have an
opportunity to look at the conditions
overnight for example I think sometimes
it saves an awful lot of time if you
were to have an informal session just
perhaps with Mr Armstrong and Mr Coleman
and then we can have a more formal
condition session on the Thursday uh
that's something to consider I I would
commend to you um but I I think if we
were to have some time on tomorrow
afternoon to do closings that that that
would be I think enough at least for my
part well I mean I suppose it rather
depends on how how quickly we get
through the um through the evidence
tomorrow um but I'm I mean let's put it
this way I'm happy however we end up in
terms of timing I'm I'm I'm very happy
to allow a period of time for for both
of you to do your closings because
frankly I would
rather allow
sufficient time for you to do it
properly because it makes my job easier
of course um if if if I have good you
know detail closings I mean they don't
need to be lengthy but um I I'd rather
give you extra time as it were to to do
that rather than have it all rushed and
and then they're not much help to me so
um we'll we'll we'll we'll see how we go
um it it may be so that if um just just
thinking around that it it it may be if
we if we have the conditions and
obligation session on the Thursday
morning the round the round table that
is not something where I expect that Mr
kanuk and I will be playing a
substantial role if any no uh so in
those circumstances so that time can
perhaps be helpfully reflected to a
degree in finalizing closing so it may
be so that if we set a closing start
time of something like I'm not sure how
long Mr kuks custom is to being closing
but if we were to start after lunch 2:30
3:00 or something like that on th this
is on Thursday afternoon Thursday
afternoon I mean the alternative is is
to to do it on on on Friday I mean in in
you know that that's the other
alternative just to allow a bit more
time I mean we have got four days it's
not as if we no no sir I I I don't I
don't need long to do my CL I mean bit
of a spoiler alert it's going to reflect
the opening um well I was going to say
your openings Mr K were were quite
detailed well it's it's just that I do I
do find on two or three day inquiries I
like to do a bit of the heavy lifting
yeah yeah no I mean look you pretty much
front loaded it haven't as as to you so
I'm feeling relatively
smug I I mean I you know sometimes
openings I I often have openings that
are sort of a couple of pages you know
something like that but yours were very
detailed so that probably means you've
got less time but let let's we we'll see
how we go we'll see how we go um and uh
we'll we'll I think we we've made good
progress today we've got we've got
through the council's evidence so that's
good um so um we'll okay we'll we'll
adjourn this evening then um are you
happy to resume again at 10: yes sir
fine sir yes yeah is that okay um so if
we resume um tomorrow at
10:00 um I don't know what the position
is I maybe the council can advise
whether we're able to leave any of items
in this room this evening or do we need
to clear everything
out I know there's a council meeting on
I think it's Wednesday evening but I'm
pretty certain you'll fine for this
evening for yeah that's that's the case
right thank you very much so that's what
we're used
to indeed indeed it's it's a novelty for
me I must say having having uh but thank
you uh for that information so you all
heard that if if you do want to uh leave
items overnight
documents and so on then you can we
definitely have a committee tomorrow
tomorrow night not clear out yeah okay
all right so we'll adjourn now then um
and uh we'll resume tomorrow morning um
at 10:00 so thank you all very
much